okay good morning everyone and can i
welcome everyone to development control
committee at mid-south district council
um just need to run through some of the
domestic arrangements before we begin
can i please ask you to ensure that you
maintain social distancing from all
other persons whilst in the chamber and
also in the communal areas
can you please ensure that you do wear a
face covering at all times unless you're
sitting down or of course you're exempt
from doing so
and can i also ask you to use the hand
sanitizers and wipes provided
please when you're not speaking can i
ask you to make sure your microphones
are turned off and please do not
interrupt other speakers or hold
separate conversations whilst others are
speaking
if you're intending to speak or or sorry
if you're attending the meeting to speak
and do persistently or interrupt we may
ask you to leave the meeting and i also
ask everyone just to double check their
mobile phones either on silent or
switched off and can i also ask you to
do with your laptops just to make the
sure the volumes right down so that we
don't get the constant pinging as emails
come in
um
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting and we use modern.gov the the
app so grass members just to make sure
you are logged on and ready to use the
app i'm trying to log on at the moment
but it's rebooting
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live on
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewings
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
if we hear the fire alarm ring today
it's not a rehearsal
so can we please leave the building
immediately via the fire exit signs and
make our way to the assembly point which
is located at ipswich town football club
please follow the signs directing you to
the fire exits at each end of the floor
and please do not enter the atrium the
ground floor area and walkways
if you are in the agent at the time the
alarm rings please follow the signs at
the nearest fire exit
please use stairs and do not use the
lifts and do not re-enter the building
too which is safe until we told you it
is safe to do so
okay so welcome to today's meeting um uh
as i said
my name is matthew hicks i'm one of the
councillors along with my colleagues
here on my left we'll make a decision on
the applications before us today
mid-suffolk district council the ward
members get an opportunity to speak
but cannot vote on the applications
before you if it is in your own ward
we have john pateman g down the end here
who's the area planning manager we have
ian de prez who's our legal advisor
and then we have
case officers who present the
applications
and mandy and claire who
keep everything to order and make sure
the meeting runs smoothly
okay um so we'll move straight on to the
agenda do we have any apologies for
absence and substitutions please
not receive chair
do we need to receive any declarations
of pecuniary or non-pecuniary interest
by members
yeah councillor
and thank you chair just to say that my
brother used to work for hopkins homes
but he left in 2019. thanks
thank you uh any other interests no
okay um do we have have we received any
decorations of lobbying
no i think that's maybe
nearly a first
okay any decorations of personal site
visits
none okay thank you
uh so we need to confirm the minutes of
the meeting that were held on the
um
sorry 8th of december
which are before us
um
in the papers
uh
are there any any points that anyone
wishes to raise yes counselor burn
um thank you chair either at the bottom
of page five or the top of page six when
where there was discussion about the the
quarry it particularly referred to
um
relation to the suffolk county council
waste and minerals plan and i think that
should be mentioned in the in the
minutes and i'd suggest that the
wording potentially is that when it says
at the top of basics officers to obtain
further clarity
regarding the expansion of the quarry
including in relation to the suffolk
county council waste and minerals plan
thank you chair
yeah we certainly did
raise that point so i think it'd be good
to have that minuted is there any other
points that anyone wishes to raise
um how do we want to play that do we
want to bring that back with the
additions rather than voting on that
today i think that'd be better okay
we'll bring that back to the next
meeting thank you
oh i've just been told there will be a
fire alarm practice at 10 a.m
so we'll
so at 10 a.m we'll just stop
uh because there's no point trying to
talk over it we'll just
with an evacuation
[Laughter]
okay well we'll we'll
play that as needed
okay it's not really
a surprise is it we all know about it
but anyway okay uh next item uh is um so
we will come back to the minutes of the
next meeting so not item number six on
the agenda is to receive a notification
of petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme have only been
received
okay
so we will go on to the uh scheduler
planning applications we will go
straight on to the first application
which is dc2101
land off bury road wool pit bearing in
mind what we've heard
um let's have the presentation from
officers and the questions and see where
that gets us to
um but i think
we might want to be a bit more
organized in our break if we can but
we'll play that by here so bradley over
to you
[Applause]
thank you share good morning members
um
this application you're being asked to
consider
is a reserve matters proposal um and
it's for the erection of 300 units on
the site at woolpit
and this follows on from a previous
grant of planning permission
thank you
yes this slide is the wider view aerial
map which shows the application site
and to the south
immediate south of the application site
you can see
the village of woolpit
and to the top right you can see
elmswell
and tostock and obviously the other key
element within that particular slide is
the a14 trunk road
this is a larger scale area map
this shows the
area in relation to the site itself i
think it's worth just noting um the
major junction you have on the uh trunk
road here which feeds into the village
where access is being taken off
of that
access sorry that junction
to serve the site
this is the redline application site
as part of the outline planning
application we granted planning
permission for 300 units plus the site
of a school
um an early year early years setting
the site of the school
is shown in the center of the site there
so it's not included within this
application this is for the residential
element only
and obviously if the school comes
forward or when the school comes forward
that would be the subject of a separate
reserve matters proposal
this is the constraint site you can see
the site itself is unconstrained the
dark brown line which you can see there
is the
settlement boundary um and there's the
historic core which contains
a lot of listed buildings in the centre
of the village
and you can see flood zones which are
nowhere near
the site we're talking about
this is the outline permission plans
i've mentioned this in the report
basically as part of the outline
planning application we felt was
appropriate to have some context plans
in order that when the reserve matters
application came in it was guided by
those so they acted as a
as almost like a framework
so the first of those that were
identified in the outline planning
permission
is the illustrative master plan which
you can see there which shows the
organization of development and
green space across the site
the second is the character area plan
they're coloured so you can see that
there's a countryside edge character
area where the site abuts
its surroundings
there's more formalised areas within the
centre which are called village greens
or open space enclosures
and there's the central spine road which
runs through the site as i mentioned
which has got full planning permission
as part of the outline planning consent
and lastly there's the open space and
landscape plan
which shows how
the framework of landscape across the
site works in relation to the built form
you'll note that there's a
a
buffer
on the western side of the development
for example between the development and
the dwellings in white house road
and also there's some an extension of an
open space area to the front here or
sorry to the east which is a
an extensive area of amenity as well
this area which is the burial ground
extension was secured as part of the
section 106 agreement
the other thing i would point out uh
quickly on this plan is that it shows
views down to the grade one village
church
as part of the
layout overall which was considered to
be a key element as part of heritage
impacts that were considered at the
outline stage
this is the layout plan that you're
being asked to consider
which
we feel as i've said in the report is is
in accordance with those
parameters that were established at the
outline stage there is a permission on
the site for 300 units this is an
application for 300 units
but the organization of the development
reflex we feel
those three previous parameter plans
this is a useful 3d view of the site um
which gives an idea um of approach or
views aerial views obviously the usual
view of the site wouldn't be like this
because we don't all own helicopters but
it just gives you an
a useful idea of the the context and how
the whole thing would plug into the
village itself
um the story height plan the development
shows arranges a range of
story heights
there's some three-story elements which
are
located
towards the center of the site around
this this village green area which i
mentioned before
which also count
sorry contains the leap
where my red dot is at the moment
um there's some single story development
predominantly
adjacent to existing development um to
the south and adjacent to the the burial
ground
and there's some instances to two and a
half story development as you go down
the spine road but the majority you will
note from the colouring
is two story
this is the affordable housing plan as a
result of viability testing at the
outline stage
it was agreed that a 20
contribution
would be um acceptable on the site
always is is appropriate um so we've
secured that and as you'll see the
location of the affordable housing which
has been agreed with the strategic
housing team um does show distribution
across the site rather than being
clustered in a particular location
this is the open space plan which
reflects the open space parameters plan
um you'll have noted the key which will
give you an idea of the various subtle
shades of of green
in terms of how this
is organized across the site as i say
it's one of the key parameters because
the interaction between the built form
and the open space was one of the ways
that we wanted to make sure that the
site was organized properly spatially
and it reflects that i think that it
does that successfully
this is a playscape designed for the
the area of play which as you can see
contains various elements of play
equipment and the circles you can see on
there are the additional tree planting
the play area itself would be contained
by bow top railings
so it will be a contained area but
importantly in terms of the organization
of the development it's overlooked by um
residential development as well
so it would be a safe space
and in terms of locations adjacent to
the proposed school site which would
make sense
this is the parking arrangement for the
site
and we've blown up the
allocation there so you can see clearly
what is proposed i'll just quickly point
out that i know that committee are not
at all keen on triple parking spaces um
and that's not been well that's been
planned out
of this um completely there's no
instances of that the other thing to
bear in mind is that i know there's
concerns generally about parking uh for
visitors
when the application first came in it
was
generally concentrated towards the south
of the development but now it's been
spread out throughout the development
and also the number
86 does exceed your your adopted
standard
you'll also note the
public car park provision here
which contains 27 spaces
that was a requirement of the outline
application in reflection of the jlp
requirement
and that's been secured and as part of
the section 106
attached to the outline
um this is the cycle path and footpath
routes map or plan
which gives you an idea of the the
permeability of the site itself
that's been a key concern and a key
driver for us is making sure that if
this land is to be built on
access across by non-car modes
is
easily achievable
since the submission
discussions have taken place
between us the developer
and the parish council
and amendments have been made to the
layout for example
the
path you can see the cycle path now
extends par right up to the boundary at
this point and would join through to an
amenity area with tennis courts and a
car park here so there's a route
straight through there which wasn't
shown before
there's also a route for pedestrians
across here that can avoid this narrow
piece of path at the front of the site
and there's also a link through for
pedestrians at this point onto
the road to the west
so generally it works as a as an
organized piece of pedestrian and
cyclists network in our view
the other things i would say is that
clearly there's going to be school
children eventually coming down this
road
in order to access the school site
to do that
there was a crossing here which would be
a toucan type crossing as i understand
to enable cyclists to cross but you'll
notice there's four crossing points in
total of the spine road
and the organization of that is such
that there'll be a toucan crossing there
um a tiger crossing here and if you
don't know what tiger crossing is it's
uh i understand it's um
a zebra crossing with a cycle route as
well
i found that out recently
um so that would be uh sorry toucan
tiger tiger
toucan so there will be
two additional cyclist routes across
there
materials man i'll quickly show you this
is
a range of materials i think bearing in
mind it's a very historic location
wool pit we've been
very aware of that in terms of the
organization of materials and the use of
development use of built form
the traditional approach which is
basically recommended in your own policy
adopted policies has been taken and the
the palette of materials which is mainly
brick
with some render and some boarding and
some slates and pen tiles is really the
palette that you would find within ball
pit unashamedly so because i think that
it does
this develops not seeking to provide
um a massive contrast to what's there
it's it's trying to be respectful of the
location and i think that
that's an important point to bear in
mind
there's some street elevations um in
terms of what you can see if i quickly
refer to my notes
take you through these
um
the top one
um is the entrance to the site
from berry road junction which is down
here
with the junction itself's got planning
permission so that would be the view i'm
not you to actually see that in reality
but that would be a view of the street
scene
the second one down is a typical street
scene along the spine road which is a
more dense element of the development
the third one is
the view from white house road
the fourth
is a street scene along
the burial ground boundary the northern
boundary the burial ground and lastly
the bottom one is the instances of
three-story development which are
focused around the that part of the site
that's got the
local area of play
in terms of the design themselves as i
said it's a traditional
um building built form that has been
expected um and encouraged um i'll just
quickly mention this particular
element this building because
there are instances within the overall
development where we have parking courts
and i know that one of the elements the
issues with parking courts is security
being able to park your cars in there
and feel that they're fairly safe
we feel that this sort of additional
element which is a flat over a garage
does provide the opportunity for
passive surveillance of those sorts of
spaces so
there are use of these across the site
which i think
is a good way of
improving that space
generally you'll see that there's a
number of
different types and
organizations of buildings so it's
terraces
uh some detached detached
larger and smaller units
and i say the architectural approach
deliberately is reflective of the older
buildings that you find in the central
wool pit
and these are some of the larger scale
buildings
which again we feel that even though
they're quit they're fairly large
um they are polite in terms of their
architectural approach
um they're well-ordered well-mannered
buildings
um
and create a
variation in the street scene which
again is something that we would look to
encourage
so it doesn't the whole development
doesn't look exactly the same across the
whole piece
and largely that's an idea of the
apartment building
cycle star and secretary cycle parking
bin storage for apartments
fairly utilitarian buildings but the
cycle parking is covered which is
important so it should be
something that people would want to use
rather than you
locate their bicycles elsewhere and
that's a typical garage detail
there'll be two substations on site
they've been located so that they are
actually within
frontages of dwellings and they're
contained within buildings it's not
purely utilitarian
functional element that's going to stick
out like a sore thumb so i think that
the developers have given some thought
to that as well
and lastly in terms of boundary
treatments um sometimes it's considered
to be a bit of an add-on and not given
much consideration but again if you look
at traditional building design built
form within the village the older field
the older
um
the older
walls for example
would include things like brick on edge
coping
rather than tile creasing
and you'd have changes in in height
actually achieved by raking the wall
down rather than having an abrupt stop
and it's it's elements like that which
adds to the overall value of the
development um rather than making it
look over utilitarian there are of
course examples elsewhere of more
functional types of boundary treatment
but they're found where you'd expect in
less prominent areas
hidden by buildings in back gardens for
example
and you haven't seen this drawing yet
but this is a key visual that we were
provided with fairly recently which
gives you two views into the site
hopefully you can just about make out
the red arrows you can see there
one looking towards the
higher buildings
and one looking into the site from
whitetail road which will give you an
idea of
how it would look
i'll finish off with some views
it's an undeveloped site at the moment
this is looking down white on road
it's
obviously previously been used for
agricultural purposes the site um
very little in the way of features apart
from built sorry from
natural features the majority of which
are to be retained and supplemented by
new planting
that's a view across the site with the
um
john's church in the distance at
elmswell which was a consideration at
the heritage stage sorry at the outline
stage
there's another view across
and there you can see a view of mary's
church grade one
and that's looking up towards the um the
new road junction
that's a view looking into the site from
where the new roundabout will be going
in which already has planning permission
um and this is
it's called the
the street which is the bottom uh
southern boundary and access is being
taken
so planning permission access has
already been granted for the
new junction at that point
um and that's the final view across i
think i'd finish off just by drawing
members attention to
the um
amendment sheet the table papers because
at the time i produced my report
we didn't have the comments from the
highway authority
or the ecology um
sorry the ecology uh officer or
landscape officer um hopefully you've
had a chance to look at the amendment
sheet but just to quickly summarize
ecology haven't got any
objections to the proposals um noting
the cons
the requirements conditions imposed at
the outline stage which is still to be
satisfied
um landscape haven't got any comments
based on the um the revised plans which
we think as i said the report addressed
their concerns
and the highway authority has identified
a revision to the route the shared
footway near plot 21. if i quickly
go back to a drawing that shows that
sorry um
just so you've got a clear understanding
of that
just need a a layout plan any layout
plan will do
oh there
um
plot 21 there's a a
no that's not showing it i don't know if
i'll put it on another one
that's about it
plot 21 is this block here
there is actually route that continues
from that point across to there
but in doing so there's a slight dog leg
in the route
so the ohio authority ideally would want
the route to be completely straight
but they're not concerned too concerned
about that but they say that the actual
final detail of that can be dealt with
under sick and the section 38 works so
they're not actually raising the
objection on those grounds it's just
a slight adjustment they might be
seeking but the route itself will be
unaffected
um but apart from that they've
recommended conditions
um which we have no issue with in terms
of
imposing on a grant of reserve matters
so in summary i think that we feel
fairly comfortable in recommending this
as an approval of reserve matters to you
thank you
thank you very much your time is perfect
because if there is an alarm at 10
o'clock it's 9 59
so i think what we'll do is um
is it is it definitely happening at 10.
okay so it's now 10 o'clock so let's
just give it
a minute and see i mean i i don't want
to start a question of them well let's
start with questions because these
things may run late but if the alarm
does sound obviously we'll we'll have to
leave the building yeah council pass
thanks um matthew yeah and i've got two
questions but the first one in case we
get interrupted uh one of the things
that's come up at previous um um
committee meetings um which i have
raised is the permeability of driveways
looking at flooding and these sorts of
things
done
so
can i remind you please not to talk
about the application until we come back
into the chamber thank you
okay so welcome back sorry about that uh
intermission for the uh fire drill
uh so welcome back so we just um heard
had the application presented to us by
uh the case officer
uh really
back to questions i've got one just to
keep the ball rolling to cancel possible
you go first and i'm coming after you
thank you um thank you very much matthew
yeah the question i was asking before we
were interrupted it's about um
drainage but particularly the
makeup of the driveways on a large
development and we had discussed the
support committee
i don't know whether it's possible to
condition it to make sure there's a
degree of permeability without of the
driveways rather than solid driveways
looking at runoff for water and so on
whether that would deem to be reasonable
or whether that's something we could
delegate to you to discuss the developer
because i think that's an important
issue if you're looking at heavy
rainfall and so on um
that's one question i got then the other
question i got if i may chairman at the
same time
it says somewhere in the papers
regarding the seal contribution to the
nhs to be determined how does it
actually work in reality because a big
development with all those people i
would imagine there would be a
request for a seal for health care and i
think it says in the paper somewhere
that that's to be determined so how does
that actually sort of work
if you have the answer to that
thanks
yes thank you councillor on the um
possibly the easier of the two answers
the um the permeability issue
we haven't agreed the materials for
surfacing
um i think that's eminently sensible
that the type of material that's used is
as permeable as possible because we have
got sustainable
urban drainage on here
um
on this particular site so
i think that
as part of the um
recommended conditions um the final
details of of that could be
but we could note that and add that as a
condition
um on the point of the sill as i
understand
a bid is made
um
on the basis of the planning approval
but the actual mechanics of that i must
admit i'm not
particularly up on so i don't know if um
john's able to advise any further on
that particular point john sorry to put
you on the spot but
i don't know if there's any anything you
further you can say to that
um i was just looking at the conditions
while he said that so i didn't quite
hear the question but i've
good point thank you
um
[Music]
the i was just looking at the conditions
and you've already got final details of
external materials boundary treatments
and hard surfacing
within the conditions so the
permeability of that would be a question
as part of that condition um the
question was about sustainable drainage
so
in terms of the allocation of funding to
the nhs and who determines the amount
and how's that amount being determined
so the
nhs funding would have been via the
outline application and the nhs would
have made a request
uh that normally comes under sill now no
this is
did
we've got figures in there for i think
education and so on but we don't have a
figure for health contribution there's a
reference to it i was just interested to
know what sort of contribution we might
be talking it might be because it's not
a 106 uh provision it comes under the
community infrastructure levy i can
check while we're talking but
just just as by way of further
information counselor the
the outline application and the section
106
we it's reflective of the the the um
basically the responses we received at
the from consultees at that time um the
nhs
at that particular time did not say that
they needed a specific amount to be
secured as a figure through section 106
agreement and they were content that the
mitigation could take place through seal
i think your your queries about how that
actually works but as i say i don't know
myself i'm afraid but they didn't
actually say that they wanted a specific
sum to be secured
as part of section 106
um can i just ask a question so um what
is the build out like have you got any
indication that likely build i build out
time for these houses because i'm very
aware that from 2026 you can't have gas
boilers
and these i understand are gas boilers
so are they plan is the plan to build it
before the 2026 deadline
uh or how's that going to work
was that really something we shouldn't
be discussing because it's not a
planning consideration
well the phasing of um there was a
phasing um
condition imposed as part of the outline
application we haven't had details to
suggest that there is being a phased
approach in safari it's going to be over
a series of individual phases and we
have the developer here so you may be
able to answer that particular
query for you in terms of build out rate
and the gas boilers
um
well as i've said in the application
report the um
the issue of sustainable
elements within the development has
already been
approved because we
impose the condition that saying
that subsequent or
contemporaneous with the outline
planning permission that was granted um
sorry with the submission of reserve
matters
they should make an application for
sustainable energy elements
to be approved and they've done so um
gas boilers are going to be used um but
the sustainable statement that they
provided does identify that the change
is required to air source heat pumps um
following the change in building
regulations so taking up on the chairs
point um if the build-out rate
extended past that point then clearly
the subsequent dwellings i would assume
would have to accord with the up-to-date
building
requirements
so we have no nothing
we have no way of having a view through
the planning process of whether they
should or should not have gas boys we've
had other applications for us where the
applicants are said actually because of
the current legislation we're now moving
away from gas and all the houses will be
air source or ground source so we have
no ability to influence that today
no that's a short answer okay thank you
uh i'm gonna just keep bringing other
members then i'll come to the ward
members at the end uh councilory burn
you know
um thank you very much chair i've got um
three questions if i may
um
firstly
the
could the
um officer just confirm
or clarify the position with regards to
the sort of stalled emerging joint local
plan
um because within the in the inspectors
discussions of that
they did say that
the council should be reviewing all
planning applications
including those that have got outline
permission so if you could just clarify
the position there with regards to this
application
secondly the um
what happens to the land for the school
if the school isn't needed because that
obviously there's been an extension
agreed at elswell so what happens to
that land
and could you confirm um
how much
of this um
how much footpath to elmswell is
actually going to be
delivered through this site because
obviously
it says sustainability is due to the as
well being able to
easily reach elms or railway train
stations so if you could
qualify that for me thank you very much
thank you um in terms of the
um if i could get the
uh plan up please
ask let's
land on the right one um
the actual provision of the footpath
is shown on this drawing here which
comes down
from the top of the junction
around
and well if he was taking the route to
the new primary school
it would you cross at that point the two
can crossing and then follow down from
that
um
in terms of the use of this site
um
if it well it's got outline planning
permission for use or
you know allocated almost as a school
if there was a proposal to use it for
something else it couldn't be pursued
under reserve matters
it would need to be the subject of a new
planning application
um
whether that would be deemed appropriate
or not would have to be considered at
that time but um as i say the
organisation of this
the way the site works
has been predicated that that is an
integral element of that particular
development so it's designed to address
that space
um
but yeah i mean that would have to be
the subject of consideration as a
separate planning application
um i can't remember sorry i'll give me a
comment what the the first point was
um it was it was to do with the just
clarifying the position with regards to
the emerging joint local plan where the
inspector said we needed to the council
should be considering all existing
planning permissions including outline
ones in the future plan and i just
wanted a clarification of how this
affects this application
thanks
uh it doesn't this so there was an
outline application this is the reserve
matters to that outline application so
it's not
being judged in principle we're just
judging appearance scale and so forth um
in respect to the joint local plan yes
there's a lot going on at the moment um
i have discussed whether or not we
should have given you a briefing ahead
of this meeting today uh with my manager
but ultimately there is going to be a
briefing coming out in respect to that
separately
but because both this application and
the next application are both reserved
matters
they are not hinged on the policy
principle of the development being there
in the first place so
we don't really need to go further than
that today
um thanks very much that for that but
just because the inspector did say it's
considering
the accounts need to consider all
outline ones at his meeting that's why i
raised that but the just the footpath
point so there's no there's no funding
put aside for a footpath
outside of the site and be you know to
get funding to get that footpath towards
elmswell
the plan um i showed you indicates a
footpath coming north of the junction
yeah um i think the way the section 106
is set up is if that's not secured
through section 273 works that the
developer would agree with the highway
authority then there's a contribution in
lieu
well the actual applications of the the
um
the red line application site this this
extends outside the red line application
site in the highway up to that point
so sorry i'm not being clear from where
your life your light is now is there any
funding to go from there towards
elmsworth up oh no i think the the
outline secured up to that point yeah
sorry
okay uh councillor mayor
thanks chief um the estate roads are
they to be adopted by the local
authority
they'll be constructed to adopt its
standards i should imagine they would be
offered for adoption
well there's rather two things there are
they just constructing them to the
standard is not the same as going
through the adoption process
yeah as i understand it the intention
was that they would build the roads and
then the highway authority would would
take them on they'd be built up to that
standard yeah thanks
councillor maths
thank you
yeah i think we'll we'll be returning to
the questions at the school and so on uh
in debate i think and the gas but the
one i wanted to look at it was the slide
12
which which showed the village green
um
the the it seemed to me that the the
three-story buildings which which were
on the south and the west sides of the
village green
would mean that the village dreamer
would spend it much of its time in in
shade which
seems to be
rather
disappointing and not not just reminding
excuses
is that
you know do we know the extent to which
i'm right in can being concerned as
the the
the angles and the size of the green and
the height of the buildings and so on
you see where i'm trying to get to with
it
sorry cancer just to be clear you're
talking about this this space here
um
yeah
yeah the the the story heights um if i
get the story high playing up as well
that's probably better
no that's going back the other way isn't
it sorry
yeah
um
excuse me
yep the in terms of
what you see here the the story heights
are three
at that point along there
three there
uh
two
there
so on that side and that side there is
three-story development the sun path as
is shown on the
the thing uh in the corner the figure in
the corner is basically around like that
so at the end of the day or past two
o'clock or past midday you're going to
get sun cast
shadow
off of these buildings but
i think in terms of a judgment the
distance away from
the actual space itself is such that
that wouldn't be enveloped in
um
shade i think there would be shading but
it wouldn't actually go right across
that space
and these units at the
the three-story units at the top
obviously being north of the sun path
the shadow is going to be cast
differently anyway so i don't think that
that in itself would be a concern um in
terms of the usability or the the value
of that as a space
okay thank you
uh councillor field did you want to come
in
yes um
basically just to return to councilman's
point i think for a minute um one of
some assurance that the adoption of
roads covers the areas identified as
shared surfaces so i believe the county
is often somewhat reluctant to adopt
roads that don't have pavements beside
them
and the obvious consequences of that is
that any management company may finish
up with some
substantial responsibilities with very
high occasional costs
so i'd like to know whether that's true
uh the second thing is really on the um
you say these sort of sustainability
issues have been agreed am i
understanding correctly that that's with
300 houses of which only nine
that's quite a small number
have
solar voltaic panels fitted
so i think
i'll reserve my other questions for the
developer but those two are for you
um on the first point
um
as i say my my understanding is that the
entire network would be offered for
adoption
including the um the private drives that
you've mentioned
um
and the shared surfaces um as a as an
entire element whether i've
misunderstood that um that will be
clarified by the developer no doubt um
in terms of the
uh
second point that is absolutely correct
the the out of the 309 would have pv
um i've given you the breakdown in my
report of what they're prepared to
to or what they've actually
put in as part of the discharge of the
condition so that would include non-pv
ones yep
okay so they really do get the climate
change issues
um
the
um
shared drive point just make the point
again that you're offered for adoption
and the county is willing to adopt seem
to be two different things
it would be nice to know one george's
position
um we actually never know we don't know
that the point here is that we can't
impose
the adoption of something on a different
party e.g the county it would be up to
the county to make that final decision
of whether wish to take those roads on i
would imagine in most cases developers
don't want the cost
to be with them and they want to push it
onto the county as quick as possible uh
and that's what normally happens but um
we can only make sure that the design
which is what's before us in terms of
the reserve matters in terms of layout
is
adoptable which is what we've done is
suitable in all other respects
and then obviously the
normal legal process between the
developer and the county will take place
i am just
sometimes it might be mentioned in the
106 i'm just going to double check now
but i would imagine it probably isn't
and it would be normally just taken as
that would be the normal process
thank you if i'll make a chair it's just
i am concerned about these issues
because
the the management company or the the
people responsible for managing the open
spaces the roads and races is not
defined i think the parish council
points out that they would like to do
some of those things but it's unclear
it's a nominated body
and experience from elsewhere in the
county is that
the costs that such nominated bodies can
pass on to their
residents can be quite dramatic and you
know from
from the very reasonable
uh like equal to our uh council the
council tax the district council levies
to several times that sum of money so it
is something that should interest us
thank you okay um councilman you want to
come back
then i want to go to the ward members
going through one one other um i i found
i was wanted to ask about really was the
i noticed that the affordables are only
20
and um can
can officers um
tell me if they that's been justified
um and
their viability has been looked at very
carefully
by us officers
um with respect members ultimately these
are issues that were dealt with with the
outline application
so i can't we haven't been prepared to
go back over the outline application in
our presentation we have only presented
the application in terms of this reserve
matters in terms of the issues that we
have to present so we have no say on
that today
okay
yeah but it's not it's not relevant
because we can't debate it or discuss it
or change it uh councillor mayor
we've been told that the the
architecture is sympathetic to the
existing village um how many three-story
houses are there in in wallpaper do we
know do they exist
they're not excuse me there are some
instances of three-story development
within the village there's not many
um
only it's two there's some two and a
half
but within the center there's some
instances of three um
in doing that i'm not counting the um
the church because of their different
completely different scale but
in the way that the site is arranged
because of the higher built form
um it was felt more appropriate to have
that towards the the center anyway to
create some sort of focal point um in
design terms whilst accommodating the
the units themselves so
it's not a completely unusual element
but i accept that it's not a an element
you'll find all over the historical
excellent
okay anyone else on the committee want
to come in notes i would now go to the
ward members so i had councillor mansell
first then councillor geek
thank you chair um all of my questions
uh referred relate to the cycle route so
could we have slide 17 up please so that
you know what i'm talking about
um firstly can you clarify the crossings
of the spine road because the crossing
point just north of the school site
has some road markings on that plan to
make it look like a pelican crossing of
two can crossing the other three points
where the blue line crosses that spine
road there are no such markings so can
you confirm that they are to be with a
tiger and two can crossings there that's
my first question second question is
there any reason why the stretch of
pavement from that roundabout to that
first two can crossing on the southern
side of the spine road cannot be a cycle
way because you've got a bit of cycleway
around the southern part of that
roundabout which just ends in nowhere so
there's a bit around the um and there
why is that not a cycle way
and my third point is relating to the
cycle route adjacent to plot 21 which
when i read that comment from highways i
assumed it meant that they were going to
use that parking court and the little
footpath and make that cycle route that
crosses there go sort of straight across
the shared surface through that parking
court and to join the roads um the sort
of
north-south roughly north south cycle
route path uh whereas the officer seemed
to think it was going to do that dog leg
round the close so can we just confirm
those three things thank you
thank you councillor the um
the first point um was to do with
crossings um
i did
see clarification on this as as late on
as yesterday in terms of form that the
crossings would take um and spoke to
what liaise with both the agent and the
highway authority um hence my advice
earlier that excuse me
that this would be the form of a pelican
sorry a toucan crossing
and you'll see some markings in the road
to suggest that
um these other two
my clear understanding is that they
would be tiger crossings the two in the
mid sorry the two let's get this
absolutely right so i'm telling you the
right thing
yeah sorry i'm
to go back to the start
um that is definitely as i understand it
a two can
two can crossing
the second one there would be
a tiger
that would be
a signalized toucan crossing and this
one would be a tiger crossing so that's
my that's my clear understanding um
i understand the final details that is
worked out through the section 38
because i think it depends on to an
extent on traffic flow
and the amount of vehicle movements
using up up and down the road
and i'm not here to give you highway
advice but um
that is my understanding of the
organization of those
on the point of the um
excuse me on the point of why that isn't
colored in blue
i have no idea is my my absolute honest
answer it doesn't appear um in any uh
document as to why that is only
pedestrian i can only assume that it's
on the basis of some highway safety
issue that's been raised but um
that's something again that the highway
authority would be
controlling through the section 38 works
so um
that's as far as i think i can comment
on that particular point
if i go back to this is probably isn't
the best
um
on the other point you raised
um
excuse me
the situation with the plot 21
and it's it's not particularly clear on
this drawing i apologize such small
scale but um there is an under the
latest scheme a situat a plan that shows
a
a part sorry a cycle and pedestrian
route going up to this point
and then there's a table junction
between these two smaller junctions here
and then there's a
where you'd actually have to go an angle
across the road and then you've got a
separate park uh park cycle parking
route
going that way
so there is
you're not actually
biking through
um
a parking court is a separate route
that's through it's just that the route
that comes up to it from the west
goes over that table and then to the
east they're not actual complete
alignment there is a slight dog leg so i
think the highway authority was saying
that they would look at that in terms of
section 38 that wouldn't mean that that
element would be lost it's just how it's
organized in terms of
the safe usage of it by cyclists and
pedestrians okay yeah you want to come
back well i'm still a little bit
confused about that cycle because
because the plan
just looks like it stops so it would
have been really helpful to have had a
plan of what we're talking about here
because i'm not now sure if it's going
on a separate path adjacent to the
parking lot well we've just been told it
does well
but but but
it's such a small scale i can't really
see where it's going well it's for the
members of the committee to decide i
think on that councillor geek
thank you chair um my uh questions were
all around the use of fossil fuels and
so i think they've been covered by your
question on councillor field's question
thank you
any other questions
okay so we'll move uh cat yes you want
to come in trump mcgee
uh just a point of clarification really
uh the question earlier was about
adopted uh road that isn't within the
106 that we have and i didn't expect to
find it i did find something though that
might be more interesting um which was
that there was a point made about the
footpaths and cycleways improvements
between elmer's will and and
warp it
obviously what's provided on the plan is
proposed but the contribution is not um
related to that it is a
set aside contribution so essentially
there was 220 000 pound contribution
towards that scheme
that is
triggered on the occupation of any of
the dwellings so
that is actually in addition to
the footpath provision as shown on the
plans just to clarify that because i
think we slightly gave the impression
that there might be one or the other it
appears to be both that's my reading of
the 106.
thank you for that
okay so we'll now move on to us public
speakers so first up is the parish
council at judah evans chair we ask you
to keep to three minutes please we have
a timer here so whenever you're ready
um
thank you mr chair my surname is ewan's
not evans just for the record
um it will be no surprise to the
committee that will pit remains opposed
to this development
it appears that present dance throne on
the joint local plan have come too late
to save woolpit we are victims of the
national and district scramble for house
building
however we are also pragmatists
outlying planning has been granted and
we must do our best to work with the
situation
we have welcomed the opportunity to talk
with the developer albeit difficult for
both parties as we had to do it over
zoom and as the planning officer has
just illustrated plans on screens are
not easy to look at
it has however been possible to agree
some minor changes
but we do not negotiate as equals
with outline planning permission in
place the developer has all the cards we
have only public opinion
the village remains concerned about most
of the
topics which have been discussed today
the urbanization of war pit the scale of
the development
reduced affordable housing unnecessary
public car parks too many hard surfaces
increased traffic speed and volume
the failure to adopt the highest
standards of energy efficiency
uncertainty about the school provision
and access to the railway
recently in woolpit we have learned a
very painful lesson
and this came at a cost to the locality
the people and the environment
a couple of years ago i came to this
committee and spoke about
a development of five houses between
rags lane and drinkstone road
we lobbied hard for protection to be
given to an ancient hedge and the
approved drawings appeared
to give sufficient develop protection
for the development to proceed
just before christmas the village was
horrified to see the entire hedge
grubbed out because the developer was
able to use the small print
it approved the draw the approved
drawings meant nothing because the
access requirements of highways
took precedence and no one in the
planning department appeared to have
checked that the plans met the highway
requirements for vision splays
we had been reassured the hedge would be
retained
however the words quote if possible
unquote were used and of course it was
never going to be possible so we ask the
committee
not to allow the use of words which give
any developer wiggle room
please eliminate words such as quote if
possible unquote or make every effort
unquote
please have regard to the detail and the
small print
you can begin here with the berry road
development there is another ancient
hedge which we have asked to be saved
and we trust you will make that
an unavoidable condition thank you thank
you very much
okay and apologies for getting your name
wrong um
any questions at all for the parish
council
no yes cancer maths
yeah can you point us to some hedges
where we we ought to take your your very
sound advice about leaving no regal room
we've seen lots of others like that in
my ward
um the main hedge that we're concerned
with is um the hedge which runs
basically from the corner of
berry road and elm and white elm
and runs up towards what will be the new
roundabout
um it is probably the oldest piece of
hedge and this was one reason why the
parish council asked the developer and
they have agreed to put a footpath that
the public can use within the site so
that the public are not walking along
the very narrow footpath but
if
that hedge is retained then the footpath
along very road that's physically next
to the road surface can't be widened
so we asked for the footpath to go
inside and
they agreed to that
and so we're just hoping that that will
be sufficient to to keep that going
okay yeah thank you is bradley able to
show us that uh on the um on the slide
somewhere
so we know exactly what we're talking
about
um i think
sorry cancer um i'll just checking that
i think if you look at the um
slide 16 that may show that in
the best detail on the presentation
sorry slide
i've changed the numbering slide 17
um
can i just remind everyone that's on
page one four five of your papers if you
want to
i think it is all one four sorry one
this one
sorry yeah the discussion that took
place
subsequent to submission has secured a
footpath behind the hedge um which i
think shown in this particular point
here obviously some hedging will have to
be removed in order to to get the um the
access in but there will be retention of
of hedging um past that point um which i
fully agree with what's been said is an
important amenity resource and there are
hedges within the site and trees which
um
the majority of which have been retained
as part of the the site you will see for
example that hedging and trees along the
boundaries here are not being touched um
there'll be some interruption of hedging
along here in order to get the spine
road in but that's gone through
consideration by the landscaping team
and also ecology in terms of impacts
and was deemed the amount to be
acceptable um
and also importantly the compensatory
planting that would be secured
by way of replacement of that
thank you
can i can i i'm sorry but no i'm sorry
i'm sorry you don't get that opportunity
to come back you've had the three
minutes i'm sorry
okay any other questions
nope
counselor geek
thank you chair um could i it would it
be within order to ask um mrs ewens what
she was about to say
that's a pity
well i mean
the the you get three minutes and we do
try and keep them i just feel i feel
sure that she was like trying to answer
the question rather than make another
comment okay we'll
we'll go with it thank you yes john
my apologies chairman and i i don't mean
to do this but can i possibly ask for
five minutes with my case officer to ask
him a couple of quick questions because
i need to know the answers before i make
a point i can ask for five minutes
please
i mean yeah i mean i should point out
that we do have a three-minute rule and
actually you do not get the opportunity
to come back beyond that three minutes
under any circumstances
but we are having a five-minute break
now and of course the ward member could
ask questions
thank you
okay so we just had a quick break there
so john paid just pick up a couple of
points drawn over to you uh my apologies
for the dramatics um ultimately i just
wanted to be sure something before i
said it and
hopefully help the debate um
the outline included a number of details
and that unfortunately included the
roundabouts and the
system around the roundabout so the
cycleway path around those roundabouts
so in going to the the hedge in question
the roundabout with the
cycle path around it on the southern end
of the development
has already been approved
the
layout which you're looking at which
includes the internal footpaths if you
like that is within your gift to look at
now without having a plan unfortunately
which is closed up in that area um the
footpath
intersects with the uh cycle lane at the
point of the roundabout now it's not
done on the highway's edge to avoid
damage to the hedge but it is done on
the internal now whether it's internal
enough is a matter of debate and whether
we need to push it back a little bit
further but that's the bit we can
control
unfortunately the bit around the
roundabout we can't now just going back
to an earlier point as well on the uh
the top road if you could put the layout
plan back up again maybe that'd be
helpful where you have the roundabout
coming in from the a14
uh it was mentioned obviously there's a
cycle uh lane on the northern side of
the road but not on the southern
side of the road i've looked at the uh
cl
as i can on here i've looked at the
close-up
version of this
physically there just isn't enough space
that's the problem um in terms of what
highway verge is available
what land is in the ownership and
control of the applicant to get a cycle
lane of the standard width on the north
side plus the width needed for a major
carriageway to go from the roundabout
through to the other side plus then to
then have enough space for another cycle
lane to the southern point
it the the road whip varies so you
wouldn't be able to have a continuous
cycle lane all the way along to meet the
standard required so instead they've
adjusted that to a pedestrian which is
obviously a slightly
shorter width
that
seems to be the logical conclusion of
looking at this of why they've only got
the cycle laying one side not the other
it might be that the applicant might be
able to talk more about that but um that
seems to be clearly the case in terms of
what land is actually available however
regardless
that was also part of the outline as i
understand it so it's not actually
something we can deal with today
council masters you actually asked a
question on this do you want to come
back i do because because the original
um outline planning commission the red
line area covered the whole
whole whole space i realized now we're
talking about a red line area which has
got that white blob removed for the
school so you're now telling me that
that that land is not within the
ownership or whatever of of this
application and yet that white blob
where the school is going to be could
arbitrarily be made slightly wider to
make it the same area and actually um
you're i've had conversations with with
mr paper g in the past about width of
cycle lanes and as i understand it it's
only an advisory width and if there is a
cycle path on the southern part of that
um roundabout people will cycle along
anyway
can you just it's just questions so do
is there a question
about the land ownership because the
original outline was the whole site
including the white blob that's been
removed for the school so how can we now
be saying there isn't enough land
thank you uh trump madrid
so in respect of the school land and the
open space area there yeah you could
widen those a little bit it's not going
to be continuous all the way through
though um
equally you've got a hedge line that's
already in existence there as well so
you've got to balance those things
together
um yes the
width of the cycle lane is
a guidance from the highways authority
and we could have a smaller
width
i'm not sure whether the county would
then take that on board as a cycle lane
themselves and adopt it that's the
question i would have and i wouldn't
know the answers to that thank you okay
any other questions at all
yes councillor geek
thank you chair um i think the question
i wanted to ask of the of the chairman
of the parish council was that in
answers to councillor passport's
question earlier we heard that the
materials for the surfacing of driveways
would be agreed to be it could be agreed
to be as permeable as possible and i
thought i wondered if that was a kind of
example of the imprecise language that
uh mrs ewens felt the committee should
be trying to avoid as a good concrete
example perhaps
the answer's just yes
yes she's nodding yes thank you thank
you
okay thank you for that
um and we'll now move on to uh we have
both the agent and the applicant here so
we now hand over to you and again you
can please keep the three minutes
thank you chairman for the opportunity
to address the committee today i'm james
all flat from bidwell's uh who are the
agents working on behalf of hopkins
homes i have john lieberman the head of
planning from hopkins homes here as well
as members may recall the outline
application for this site was approved
by this committee nearly two years ago
since this time we have been working
with your officers and key stakeholders
including walpip parish council to
develop the detailed design for the site
based upon the land uses and the
parameters approved by that outlying
consent during the course of this
application in response to comments from
both the paris council and mid-suffolk
disability forum the applicant has
revisited numerous house designs to
ensure that 87 properties achieve
compliance with par m42 which are
optional requirements to secure
accessible and adaptable dwellings
positively responding to the emerging
local plan
whilst outside the scope of this
application the design team have also
been engaged with suffolk county council
to ensure the access requirements of the
school site have been incorporated into
our designs
whilst the council has discharged
condition 16 of the outline planning
permission which agrees the energy
strategy for this site hopkins homes
have reviewed its proposals further and
intends to heat all dwellings on the
development via air source heat pumps
subject to the school not requiring gas
there is the potential for this site to
be free of any gas requirements the
outline planning permission also
includes a condition requiring the
details of electric vehicle charging
points to be submitted prior to the
commencement development the these
details will be submitted in due course
the site through its landscape design
and habitat creation achieves a
biodiversity net gain of 16
including new native scrub planting on
boundaries species-rich wild flower and
new tree hedgerow planting alongside the
installation of bird boxes as standard
across the development
there are three drainage basins across
the site which form part of a surface
water drainage strategy which has been
approved by the lead local flood
authority the basins have been designed
to be shallow and will be dry during the
vast majority of the year the side
slopes no steeper than one in four which
meets the requirements of the lead local
flood authority the basins also include
benches which are a safety feature
provided providing steps out of the
basins post and rail fencing and
landscaping both within and around the
basins are proposed to restrict access
subject to securing approval of this
application the intention would be to
commence on-site later this year with
first occupations being expected by the
end of 2023 and completion by 2029
it is anticipated that the development
will commence from the north of the site
to bring the construction traffic via
the a14 junction avoiding construction
traffic through the village
in conclusion scheme before you is one
which we believe represents a
sustainable viable and deliverable
solution to bring forward a
landscape-led development which has
undergone extensive consultation and
therefore urged this committee to
approve this application in accordance
with officers recommendations so that
hopkins homes may commence delivering
this high quality and sustainable
extension to the village of warpit
helping fulfill both its housing and
wider infrastructure needs thank you
thanks very much for that so just to
just um because it you you got through a
lot of information very quickly there so
thank you for that so it's air source
heat pumps throughout
that's correct okay thank you electric
charging points throughout
there they'll be details provided as
part of the outline planning condition
yes okay thank you very much
yes council humphreys
mr thank you sorry about my voice first
first of all um there's no possible in
that is that it's we are definitely
going down the
air um heat source pump route there's no
possible no change of words that's
definitely what you're going to deliver
that's correct thank you
council passport and council maths
very quickly the issue about
permeability of driveways i know you
can't be precise about that but actually
it's really really important that is of
a concern to the committee and other
people
is everything and i don't mean just
possible there is going to be a real
commitment um
for that please
yeah so we've worked hard with the um
lead local photo authority to agree the
surface water drainage strategy so that
that encompasses various elements
including the basins i spoke about so
for the driveways um
the private drives at this point aren't
proposed to be permeable the um other
shared surfaces are are proposed to
contain permeable material and they form
part of the wider surface water drainage
strategy which as i say has been signed
off and agreed by the lead flood
authority
council madison
thank you yeah well the the the late
change of the energy strategy is very
very welcome
and what i was wondering was that if if
you're going over to that
that more electricity based
approach
have you reconsidered the very small
number of pv um panels that are proposed
um
according to bradley at least
so yeah as i said the the energy
strategy has effectively already been
discharged but the the late check or the
further change to air source heat pumps
will require us to go back in and
redischarge that energy strategy
and and we're now working through the
the detail of that so s or c punch will
certainly be one element of that um what
that means for pvs and and the rest of
the scheme in terms of achieving at
least 10 percent from renewables
is yet to be be determined but
just to assure members that the energy
strategy that will be going forward will
be in excess of that 10 because of the
the switch to air source heat pumps for
all the dwellings
thank you so yeah just just to clarify
so what what we're saying is you're now
going to use you're going to increase
the electricity demand
of the of the site effectively quite so
and the the the 10 renewables will be
achieved
by putting some more pv panels on in all
probability then yeah
but the condition actually requires ten
percent so s or seats pumps contribute
to that ten percent no no they they
they use electricity
the
you're going to produce ten percent of
the electricity that's needed
through renewables i think i think
that's what we
will finish up
agreeing with
we
well as i say what we need to go back in
and redischarge that energy strategy
including air source heat pumps um the
conditions says renewable or low carbon
energy technologies so um
we we will obviously provide that detail
to the authority for redischarge under
that outline condition so can i just so
what we're basically saying is you're
going to have to register re-discharge
that
so
through that that will mean that they're
therefore because you're doing that
therefore you have to meet the current
requirements which is ten percent yeah
thank you
okay uh councillor
so yeah that's very much similar to the
point so
presumably officers that means that the
the new energy strategy will go back
past our sustainability process
again exactly and they'll meet the
requirements can we minute that we have
in our well they'll meet the polit
whatever our current policy is
john
um i don't want to be the the doom maker
but ultimately right now i can only we
can only say what's actually happened to
this point which is that we are dealing
with the strategy that has been
discharged in its current form whether
the applicant and would respect whether
they come back and change it will have
to be something for later it has to be
determined on its own merits and i don't
really
i need to be
careful not to because it's the point
the parish council made it's it's a
commitment but obviously that works
still underway and that's not what's
before us today
ultimately i will stress this the
heating of these houses
and the
connections in that respect are not
before you at this moment in time this
is a reserved matters application and i
think we are going to be in dangerous
territory we start thinking that
something is going to happen which makes
an impact and prejudices your view on
the reserve matters that are before you
i think i think we can
look hopkins homes are a big company
they've said in a public meeting that
the houses will all be sourced funds i
think it'd be very difficult for them to
change that view having stated it in
this meeting so i think but we just have
to take that on board okay councillor
field you were next
well it's more than minuted it's been
aired publicly councillor uh
field you were next
i think you've covered the points i was
going to ask um i i was going to check
that the
despite the fact you're using uh gas
boilers that the
heating devices radiators or whatever
they shall be will be sourced for the
the low temperature feeds that you will
get when
occupants use the government's new
subsidy scheme to throw their gas
boilers away you seem to have covered
that so i think that's okay
the other obvious one is that you will
be ensuring that the
electricity supply to the houses will be
sufficient to support
air source heat pumps plus car charging
i guess we've really covered that so i
think
um
just that uh one one struggles a bit
while we can't put a condition on
requiring um
the
the sustainability statement to be
re-examined is a bit difficult to follow
but uh
okay okay thank you end of question as
well okay
just a request really um when you do
look again at the sustainability issues
will it be possible rather than
establishing a minimum number of houses
that have um solar voltaic panels
perhaps
sorry treat it as a minimum offer that
as a package to all your vendors all the
um purchasers so that it is perhaps an
option that people can take so we see
those panels on a far greater percentage
of the houses
council even
thank you very much chair and thank you
for the applicants your comments um
i've got three questions if i may um
firstly the bungalows the 16 bungalows
could you um confirm what percentage of
those or how many of those would be m43
on building rigs please and if you
haven't got any figure in mind could we
have a figure please um for that um
secondly
the public car park
where that's situated it's about 500
meters or so from the co-op
um
what was the
you know i presume in some way there was
a need somewhere for this car park but
it's was there consideration made to
locate it next to the tennis courts
car park because the
there's a thriving tennis club and
cricket club that dearly need more car
parking space um so was consideration
made to have the car park the other side
of the site next to the tennis courts
thank you and thirdly
um the three-story buildings um
the
that's it's very unusual in a village
setting yes there are story buildings in
in wool pit one of them is the pub
a couple of them others are
public buildings and um sort of key
key residential houses but it's quite
unusual to have three-story new
buildings
could you explain the
rationale
for that because it does make it quite
an urban setting thank you very much
thank you
thank you um yeah just to take those in
turn in terms of m43
one of the bungalows is fully compliant
with m43
in terms of the village car park that
was
part of the outline planning permission
in terms of identif with the outline
planning permission was a series of
parameter plans which identified the
spatial distribution of land uses across
the site including the village car park
and the siting of that was was part of
the approval of those plans and
obviously the section 106 that was
attached to that outline consent has a
requirement for a specification and
design for that car part to be brought
forward
um prior to first occupation so
in terms of where it's located in terms
of the detailed design that that's been
driven by the parameters that were
established at the outline stage
and the final question about three story
um
i think as your planning officers
highlighted in in his presentation
the introduction of three stories is to
bring some variance in character and
bring a focal point particularly around
areas of of play and open space
particularly in the area immediately
opposite the the proposed school
it was felt that that was an entirely
appropriate
arrangement for three-story development
in that location which has been
supported by by the council's internal
consultees as well as landscape officers
yeah please do
um thank you very much for that if i can
just come back on the car park um
because the
the title of our
um reserve matters today does say
appearance landscaping layer layout and
scale forward
village car park so it is included um so
could you just um respond to say whether
it was considered to be near the tennis
courts or that was the only site for the
the car park thanks very much as part of
preparing the reserve matters we haven't
considered locating it towards the
tennis court car park um you obviously
heard from your own officers that we've
been in dialogue with the parish during
the course of this application and
extended the the footway cycleway
connections from the site to the tennis
court car park to provide that
connectivity but the village car park
itself has always been in that location
okay uh we have no other members of the
committee so we'll go to the ward
members oh i'm sorry
yeah i i you as the chair said you did
go through a rather fast um
i did i heard you mention him for two
but what was the
what was it you were offering in terms
of of m42 compliance
87 87 of the properties will be m42
compliant and one m43 yeah okay thank
you
cancer field
sorry one element i forgot um just the
the issue of management companies is
clearly um a statement there will be one
i wonder what the uh your attitude to
that is because i'm aware that
the antics of such companies is
controlled for
leaseholders there's considerable
constraints on them but for freeholders
there is no constraint on
their
subsequent charges and activities
how do you as a
concern cope with that
i think if i pick up the management
company piece initially then i'll pass
over to hopkins homes to provide a bit
more detail um under the outline in 106
there's a cascade effectively for the
transfer spaces we've certainly had
dialogue so far with the parish council
which suggests some of the spaces
might be taken forward by the parish
alternatively there are the mechanisms
and management companies are one of
those um if i pass the
to jonathan but i think it's fair to say
management companies are a very common
feature in in modern developments and
certainly hopkins homes developments but
jonathan did you want to add anything
yeah no thanks james happy to answer
hi my name is jonathan lieberman head of
planning at hopkins
so just to add on on that in respect to
how that would work uh effectively
a limited company's set up
at the point
that the development commences and
when a
resident purchases a property they
effectively become a shareholder of
the the management company and
they will then
enter into an obligation to
make payments annual payments which
would then maintain the open spaces and
unadopted areas
but at the point of last
sale
hopkins would then effectively
hand over control
to the management company so to the
residents
and at that point the management company
and the residents have an option either
to set up a board for example that would
then
uh organize the management of those open
spaces or they could appoint a an agent
so effectively they are shareholders of
their company which in turn they have a
an interest in obviously uh how the the
spaces are managed but also the the
costs etc
okay thank you so the point you're
making is that the residents will
maintain a strong level of control
that's satisfactory that's right yeah
i'm not going to move on to questions
from the ward members cancer geek
thank you sir this seems like a small
point compared to the uh ones that have
been raised around uh sustainability
renewable energy sustainability in its
true sense but the mid-suffolk
disability forum have commented on page
65 of the report that every effort
should be made to ensure all footpaths
are wide enough wheelchair users
and that any dropped kerbs absolutely
level with the roads that's not in the
conditions at present and even if it was
we've got that work those words every
effort that that's unlikely to be enough
given what we heard today about the
recent loss of that ancient hedgerow in
drinkstone road that was going to be
retained if possible
should
is there a chance that that can be taken
on board
so could you just tell me the page
number again i can't find it in my copy
oh 65.
um
um
well both of those requirements are now
currently in in the highways uh guidance
as required um
so and given the fact that these are
likely to be adopted i can't see why
this wouldn't be achieved
for the avoidance of doubt
i would have no problem with an
additional condition to that effect
but
i i don't see it necessary but for the
avoidance of doubt it can be done
50 yeah 1500 is the standard whip
it's just the drop curves to be
absolutely level well there's level and
there's absolutely level um you know i
don't know about you but there's always
that inch possibility i think are they
literally looking at that smoothness of
transition for a wheelchair user um
we're getting into that
nth degree
um
[Music]
consideration
sorry um looking at page 65
all dwelling should be visible and meet
part four
brackets one
and at least fifty percent of the
dwelling should meet accessible and
that's all standard part
um m4 part two so we've only got 87.
is that an issue
it's not currently your policy to insist
upon that requirement
so it might be in the future um
depending on the joint local plan uh but
it is not your current local plan policy
um and we do not have a means to insist
upon it
okay thank you
right so we now move over to the ward
members um to have your say on the
application uh councillor geek you want
to go first
yes thank you chair
this development should not have been
given consent in the first place and
there were many reasons not to give
consent which were all ably explained by
councillor ebern at the meeting that
originally granted the outline
permission but of course we are where we
are
and although no one can make a silk
purse out of a sow's ear perhaps it
might be possible to wrestle some tiny
improvements out of the situation let's
start with car parks
wool pit parish council has been able to
negotiate some changes as we've heard
with hopkins homes but again as you've
heard has been unable to remove that
unwanted car park despite strenuous
efforts surely there must be some way we
could find to swap this new car park
which is in entirely the wrong place in
favor of improvements to that existing
parish council-owned car park that's
just outside the southeast corner of the
development by the tennis courts in a
much more practical location
but if not if we have to have that
so-called village car park please at
least let it have a usable footpath to
the center of the village as you'll see
from slide 16 in your report page 144
there are no improvements planned to the
current perilously narrow one if um if
mr heffer could give us um slide 48 from
his presentation that's got a very good
photograph of the footpath in question
which is only 75 centimeters wide
um
here again by the way an improved
footpath should be put within the site
so we retain the hedge you'll see it in
a minute
not it shouldn't be at the expense of
the hedge that you will see
you will you will
um in addition the separate burial
ground car park is also not wanted
um
here we go next one lovely see that tiny
little little footpath 75 centimeters
wide i measured it last night um
the separate burial ground car park is
equally not wanted the car parked to the
south east of the estate that tennis
club car park
it's located between the church yard and
the new burial ground it's in a far
better position for serving the burial
ground if we remove the burial ground
car park that would allow greater
capacity for burials in the burial
ground and will minimize disruption to
the residents in the quiet cul-de-sac of
haybarn meadow
where otherwise funeral courtesies would
have to go
a gate for maintenance vehicles is all
that's needed there but again if we
can't persuade you to take the burial
ground car park away please let it have
a permeable surface at present it looks
like it's down to have a hard surface it
could have reinforced grass i mean not
just permeable something where a plant
could grow would be great now the
monetary cost of those two car parks
that are not wanted or needed by the
village and which are in the wrong place
the monetary cost of course will fall on
the developer but the carbon costs of
constructing these things will fall upon
us all and the lack of biodiversity of a
hard surface will fall upon us all
and finally
one other thing on the subject of carbon
costs
it's great to hear about the air source
heat pumps
but i am worried that that will provide
a trade-off with the with the solar pv
and yet again here we are with a problem
with the orientations yet again we have
a development with the buildings
orientated for aesthetics rather than
energy efficiency there are a lot of
buildings in this development with no
part of the roof facing south or even
nearly south now even if we have to
accept as i'm constantly being told that
solar panels can't be fitted as standard
and they have to be expensively and
tiresomely retrofitted please can we at
least build houses that have a roof that
could theoretically accommodate them the
only thing that's more irritating than
having to put solar panels on your house
yourself when they could have been built
by the builder six months ago is that
you you find out that your roof can't
accommodate them anyway
the estate is not at all sustainable
that's in the old sense sustainable as
it stands
um the fossil fuel heating i've crossed
out but lack of footpaths pointless car
parks and these just nine houses
equipped from the start with solar pv of
course we shouldn't have to reiterate
this to the applicants mid-suffolk
district council all of us have agreed
that we are in the midst of a climate
emergency the applicants should
routinely be taking this into account
and i'm very disappointed that they
haven't
thank you councillor
manson
uh thank you chair um you you've now
heard from both walpip parish council
and councillor geek about their concerns
uh over this application and i agree
with all that they have said and i will
try not to repeat uh anything that
counselor geeks already mentioned there
is no doubt that some people will
consider this development as a carbine
called tacked onto the picturesque
historic village of woolpit
but as as has been said before we are
where we are with the site having
outlined permission for up to 300
dwellings so we now need to ensure that
this development has the optimal
sustainability and layout this will in
effect be the gateway into the village
from the a14
it's refreshing to hear that developer
has made some effort to engage with the
parish council but we don't think that
they've gone far enough
so
aside from the comments that council
geeks already mentioned
in terms of the layout we have small
market apartments which are clustered
around the play area near the school
site is this the best sort of layout
surely one and two bedroom apartments
are not going to be inhabited by
families who will surely be the main
users of both the school and the play
area
we also need to know councillor
matheson's comments regarding the
shading of this open space again is that
an optimum layout
we've heard comments regarding the
disabled access requirements uh for this
development and they are at the bare
minimum again this is an optimum layout
or design of development
i won't go on about the car park
um but uh i completely agree with
councillor geek um i i'm a bit against
the concept of residence management
companies for public open space when at
outline permission
we're we're told to regard that the
public open spaces are some sort of
mitigation uh for the fact that this bit
of countryside is going to be developed
and surely they should be the use of the
wider community not just residents of
this development and i would strongly
urge that the developer does all that he
can to make sure that the parish council
is able to take these on
um with regards to the school
and access to the school i understand
that the school is not part of this
application but access to the school is
part of this that the the access points
um this is one of the main concerns of
elmsworld parish council because um it
is expected or
we we think it's likely that there will
be a reasonable proportion of pupils at
the school who come from elsewhere
um
and although we've got this promise of a
psychopath which i'll go on into in a
little bit more detail there will be a
number of people who will be being
driven to that school
and you know the fact that they're going
to be these cars accessing the school
going through the housing estate again
is is that a good layout
and of course there's still some
uncertainty about whether the school
site will actually be needed by the
county council
right uh in terms of the cycle paths um
it's it's good that we've got cycle
access through the development to get
into the center of the village via the
car park by the tennis club
uh i'm still a bit confused about the
cycle path adjacent to plot 21 um and
that
hopefully will get itself sorted out
uh with regard to the cycle access from
the outside of the village uh in
particular from elswell until that new
bike path that we are being keep being
promised over the a40 there is no safe
access to the cycle routes through the
site
the paths on both sides of that spine
road should be cycle paths especially in
that first section closest to the new
roundabout until that new bike path is
complete anyone cycling from elmswell
over the a14 bridge to that roundabout
would be on the other side of the road
the safest way of getting onto the bike
path is to go all the way around that
roundabout but effectively you're then
on the wrong side of the road so it just
makes no sense to me it you'd end up
having to cross it twice
and it will cause cyclists to make a
dangerous maneuver to either rejoin the
carriageway or negotiate their way onto
the cycle path on the north side of that
spine road and
what use is a contribution triggered by
first occupation of this development for
the cycle path to elmswell that's just
the money coming in surely this bike
path needs to be in existence before
first occupation not we'll collect the
money before the first occupation uh you
know it really is not
it's not a
sustainable development because of the
cycle access uh between elmswell and
warpit
thank you
okay thank you very much do we have any
questions from the ward members before
we go into debate
no okay members well it's over to us now
to discuss
sorry councilman yeah
they
for either either world member really um
in terms of the existing schools in the
two villages and the existing um school
rolls
do we do we know if there's already a
significant number of elmsworld children
going so really sorry john that's not
relevant to the application before us
it's going to be something relevant to
the application the school
not part of this application
we've been hemmed in too much on this
i'm sorry
it is not part of the application i've
asked mr duprez and he agrees we're here
to talk about the application before us
if you i have no problem talking about
what's before us but not
an application that isn't before us
it's part of the the the outline
permission that's been granted but you
your reserve matters before you today
and does not include the school and that
is a that it's not a wrong or unlawful
necessarily for reserve matters to be
to be not a complete full set of the
whole site reserve matters
i'm happy to anything else
nope okay so over to us discuss debate
and come to a conclusion yes councillor
humphreys you've got your hand up first
mr thank you um it's certainly a couple
of small points i actually like this
development um i like the layout of it
um the three-story housing i don't find
that to be too offensive to be honest
with you as we've already said in the
historic part of woolpit there are three
story buildings and also the position of
them with the slope and everything else
i think it fits in quite nicely and it
does give that central point so
personally and it is a personal thing i
guess design um i quite like it i've got
no real issues with it i do want to
cover the solar panel issue everybody
keeps talking about orientation
orientation must be south well if all
houses face south what a boring
structure we'd have across the country
of straight lines we don't want that but
also it's not strictly true and i've
just done a quick internet search and i
knew this anyway because i've looked at
solar panels but on eco homes it talks
about positioning it's not just position
it's elevation elevation is the key and
elevation is critical as well
but if i just look at the graph in front
of me a house that's 180 degrees 30 to
40 degrees elevation roof pitch gives
100
fantastic that is the ideal and i get
your point completely
if i move to the left to the south west
the same elevation
it drops only to 94 percent same to the
east so actually we're talking about
small margins
and i get the importance of it if we can
get absolute 100 all the time fantastic
we're not in that world it's boring this
is an estate it's designed in a
particular way to be appealing to the
people who want to buy it and actually
they can still get the energy that they
require from the sun just not as much
so um this is uh typical hopkins layout
uh design of houses it's nothing we're
not unused and used to within suffolk
and i quite like the design i quite like
the layout and at the moment i'm going
to go for it but i'll wait until we've
heard from other uh members of the
committee thank you
thank you council password
um thanks very much chairman yeah i
agree with a lot of what uh councillor
humphreys has said i think it is um
important we remember we are just
looking at the reserve matters and not
other issues so we know the the
development go ahead and i do think
there has been quite a lot of movement
from what i've heard from the questions
and replies from various people to
make it much more sustainable and i'm
very pleased also to hear about the
energy
sources that are being used there
hedge protection i think is particularly
important in the way that the one of the
foot passes you move to the other side
i do actually take up i think it was um
helen g made the point about a footpath
from the car park to the center of the
village that seems to me to be eminently
sensible i don't know if it's possible
to condition that i'm told it's not so
forget that one then um and i'm also
very um amused and interested to hear
about tiger crossings i've never ever
come across them before but but
seriously i do think it's been
um laid out very very well we can only
look at what we've got as a say and we
can only make recommendations within the
remit um according to our planning
office so i am actually going to propose
that we do
um
approve this chairman formally um
having listened to what council the
humphreys have said um and i just want
to be clear about the permeability i
think has that been covered i think the
head planning officer did actually say
we could can condition that to a greater
extent because i do think that's really
really important that we work together
for future rainfall heavy rainfall and
drainage but i do understand the agent
applicant did cover that so i would like
to add that
as a condition so that's it thank you
chairman
thanks so much council e burn you in
there
thank you chair um um as per you know my
comments on the outline application you
can um imagine i'm not 100
um
satisfied with this one before us today
um
i think a couple of things that
i'm particularly concerned about
i'd like to see an actual time frame for
this bike path to elmswell
there is no point in putting more
housing in here and expecting people to
cycle to elmswell
as soon as they've moved in
when there's nothing safe for them to do
so um i think
i'm not sure that we can have an
informative on the
with regards to the open space to ask
for further discussions between the
developer and the parish council for
them to um
take on the open space um
while while the development hasn't yet
been approved
and um i'm
can and i'd also like to see a condition
that actually says protect
and secure
the hedge from the access point to the
corner of berry road and white helm
road
and
i'm
concerned about the you know i
appreciate that the developer has had
discussions with the parish council and
that is appreciated
but
things like this car park where the the
parish is crying out for improved car
parks for the much used and loved tennis
courts and the very very successful
cricket
ground
it just seems bizarre to me that
that those discussions have led to a car
park being placed where it is that will
end up being used by visitors
to people who are visiting friends
relatives on the site and probably not
by um
you know those visiting the village or
wanting to have access to the church the
cricket ground the
you know the pub in the town set in the
town i'm calling it town because it
seems like a town in the village center
so um you know it's disappointing that
those discussions couldn't um
be
have
actually manifested in something that
the
residents really need um i'm
disappointed with some aspects of it i
can't see enough in it to
warrant refusal but i'm i would really
like to see those elements um actually
um
improved to to go forward and the
another point really is just to have one
bungalow as part four part m43 and
building regs is a bit mean given the 16
and it would be good if we could see
more than one thank you chad can i just
pick up on a couple of points with john
payton g around the open space and
around elm the cycle lane to elmsra
could you just pick up on that what is
our what are we able to do or not do
so the um the 106 agreement well there's
two elements there's the footpath that's
part of the site itself obviously that
will be built in a phase form as part of
the development there's the footpath
link between elmsworld and woolpit
that is the county county county council
are essentially collecting money from
various sites to kind of get a pot
together i think i think the pot needed
is something like seven hundred and
something thousand pound um i think
there's a shortfall on that at the
moment
and it's for them to
collect that money this would be a
contribution towards that
some 200 odd thousand um collect that
money and for the timing of
implementation of that link would be for
them to administrate and i can't
add anything now to the 106 that's
already been
signed off to go into any timings
for for that link that link is
something else that has to be dealt with
by the county in its collection of all
the allocations the ones that are well i
say allocations
in a strange way now at the moment but
while we're sorting that out um the
monies from anything in elmswell and uh
woolpit are going towards that and
really until they get that collective
sum together or at least
majority of it together the timing i
suspect will be reliant on that of when
that comes forward and i can't speak for
the county in that respect can i just
flag up the final point that uh that
councilman made around protecting
securing access to the hedge line from
the access point to is it white elm road
yeah is that something we can condition
so very quickly um
you can put informative on anything you
like in terms of open space but open
space ultimately
is controlled by the 106 in terms of who
he goes to and where
the hedge now that can be something we
look at because ultimately that is part
of the landscaping which is part of what
you're looking at um
i will talk last brad here is
that there would be no issues that
you're aware of putting a condition on
that hedge to ensure that it is fenced
and protected or is that part of the
landscaping
strategy that we already have the
outline application is subject to series
of conditions including landscaping
um
which we would look to secure
um as part of the any hedge feed details
we look to secure as part of that
condition
excuse me however
i don't expect that there'll be any
particular issue with a
a focus condition one particular element
within the landscaping as part of the
reserve matters we we can
condition
that hedge specifically okay uh um
council humphreys
mr thank you i'd like to second the
proposal for approval and i'd like to
have that condition added to protect the
um the hedgerow which has been speaking
around which is at white elm road
formally
thank you thank you
no one else has put their hand up yeah
oh councilfield then councillor
matson
thank you
we always say this is difficult i do
find the layout uh
quite acceptable in many ways
uh it looks quite interesting there are
the issues of um
roads that may well finish up not to be
adoptable but i i guess one can live
with that
upon the overall issue of
house orientation
and the lack of the ability to put pv
panels on part of sustainability
an issue of quite considerable concern
we seem to be
persistently building
putting out buildings that we can't
equip with
such
energy sources
and yet uh you know my particular ward
is faced with 350 megawatt
solar farms gobbling up
land
and
provision on house routes or building
roofs is something which if you like is
free of any additional land usage
the other issue i guess is the actual
insulation standards of the houses we're
building we we all know this has to
improve
quite dramatically
and we're offered 10
better than the 2013 building rigs
2013 is what eight or so years ago
um
you know it's an outdated standard we're
not building to the future home standard
which we understand won't be around for
another couple of years
and that seems a matter of
in many ways just the will to to make
improvements
the the the current building rigs
require
uh windows with a u-value of two and you
can readily buy them with a u-value of
0.8 so you know these are things that
could be
improved and actually perhaps at an
initial cost to the purchasers but over
a relatively short period
at a substantial reduction of their
purchase costs as their running costs
and and
a reduction in the costs they're going
to have to pay for to retrofit these
buildings with with such things in a
fairly short time
it's quite clear that the air source
heat pumps is a welcome move i'm pleased
to see that there's a a sign of
responsibility from a major builder so
yeah i'm inclined to agree with
councillor eben that there isn't
sufficient
reason to
reject this application but i certainly
feel that we should be able to do better
thank you councilman matheson and
councillor mann
well council of fields last last words
are um yeah exactly so we should be able
to do better uh on the detail um i must
say given a greenfield site which this
is i'm i'm baffled
the the um
the problems of there isn't enough land
and enough width to produce a a cycle
path
on both sides of that road
um
and
having from time to time cycled from
elmsworld station to get to wool pit via
what's there at the moment which is
highly unsatisfactory and very dangerous
um
really we
i absolutely hear what council
mansell's saying that the cycle
arrangements just aren't right and
aren't good enough
um
but on the
broader bigger picture
somewhere at the beginning of the um
mppf and i'm sure
mr payne mcgee can find it if we're
interested um you know we have a general
responsibility to to deliver good
planning
and i i think that the
the situation with the the two villages
and the schools
with the with the site being offered in
the wrong village essentially
compared to where it's needed you know
that is not good planning the public
will look at that and say this is not
good um why aren't they putting the
school where it's needed in elmswell
and and
also
um the the other thing that worries me
that we haven't really probed into and
no doubt would be told we can't um is
whether the
the electricity grid
set up is sufficient to deliver and i
think counts the field um you know
hinted that with the air source heat
pumps and the electric vehicles the
demand for electricity is going to go up
and up
and i'm
mindful that when the this council was
putting pv panels onto
council houses
i was not able to get them put on a row
of of council houses for the reason that
the local grid was not sufficiently
strong to stand up to the electricity
that might be generated so that the grid
has got questions to ask as well and i
think that this
you know as the local planning authority
we have a general responsibility
to see all these other things getting
sorted out
outside of the
reserve matters that we're looking at at
the moment and and i do think that we we
we are being unduly restricted
um
by by the
decisions that were made three years ago
on the outline and if if some of those
really need revisiting then i think we
also have the courage to actually say so
so i'm not really very happy with this
at the moment okay well i mean there's
the planning process you go through a
series of hoops we can only discuss
what's before us today i'm sorry you're
unhappy with that uh counts councillor
mayor you were next
thanks chief
um generally i
like development whether or not you
should be there is a decision that's
long long gone that boat has sailed
um i applaud the parish council's
willingness to take on the open spaces
and i think it's
you know i would really encourage the
developer to engage with the parish
council
setting up limited companies to manage
open spaces for my mind is a recipe for
disaster um down the road so
more power to the parish council's elbow
it's also disappointing the car park
appears to be in the wrong place we
can't really talk about that um
but let's not forget that um this
development will generate a lot of sil
money that will go to the parish council
so if they want to develop the cricket
car park or the tennis car park that is
within their remit to do so um so
there's still a way
forward there
i do think it's very sad that
from nine
from 300 houses only nine are going to
have solar panels
i honestly believe there's a demand out
there
i think people purchasing these houses
will engage and will pay more for that
sort of facility
so again i'd encourage the developer to
treat that as a minimum and look to be
able to deploy that sort of resource on
as many houses as possible
i think this is a
pretty sound development i will support
the motion
proposal sorry
okay well we've had everyone speak yes
counseling
um thank you chair if i if i just may
come back because i've just looked up
the section 106 agreement with regards
to the open space and it just says for
the landowner to agree with the district
council for nominations it doesn't say
in the in the s section 106 that it will
be a management company so i really
would like to see something saying that
the um developer should discuss this
further with the parish council if the
parish council wishes to take that we
can only put an informative in along
those lines
is that john do you want to come in
is that correct
you can burn informative
anyone else wish to come in
yeah councilman matthewson yeah are we
are we on to talking about conditions
with the proposal now essentially
um
right well i
i'm i'm reliably informed that house
martins are now are now um
of species at risk alongside of swifts
and and that there is a thing called a
house martin cup
which can be put onto houses
so i wonder if we could just extend
swift nest bricks to include house
martin cups as well
and and i think we need to condition the
um
the
m4 two and three
um that we've been we've been offered
um
that that should be a condition as per
uh or not quite as much as what um
disability forum asks for on page 65
um so if
i think i'll bring in trump like that
those two i think we'll bring john in
because i think we were told that we can
only condition to our policy which isn't
necessarily the same as the
that section so john
okay so um what is before us in terms of
reserve matters is appearance
what goes on inside the property is not
design
no it's not designed
reserved matter is not design it's only
appearance
layout
scale
and unfortunately i don't disagree with
you i do actually think the nature of
reserve matters perhaps needs to be
significantly expanded but that's my
personal opinion um unfortunately in
terms of the statutory
planning system for the last 20 years
we've only got those to play with
and it is a reconstraint on what we do
here
i so therefore i can't employ that
condition because it would effectively
deal with the entire internal
arrangement of properties i can't employ
that to to put it on in my opinion my
professional opinion um
in terms of the other thing the other
thing was uh house martin's
now
it's not actually reserve mata but the
good news about that is we actually have
another duty under the wildlife act so
we pinch it and put it underneath that
so i can we can add that to it that's
not a problem
okay we've persuaded various other
developers to deliver us a few m4 two
and three compliant properties um we
have we not written that in anywhere
into what we've we've persuaded we have
no policy basis and in this case we have
no
actual
basis to deal with that as an issue
before us all right all right john i
share i know your frustration but we can
oh i'm going to come back to the
original point we can only discuss what
we're allowed to discuss with what's
before us today and we can't straighten
and be more creative in our workings
well um you know that's for you to take
up outside of this meeting i think
okay so i'm now going to go to council
passport and council humphreys is
anything else you wish to add before we
go to the vote
okay so i'll hand over to yeah
just briefly by clarification i um
earlier advise you that there was a
landscaping condition imposed on the
outline there is in fact a landscape
management plan condition which is a
different thing we would actually agree
the landscaping condition details or
landscaping details as part of the
reserve matters approval so the point
about the um the elements with the the
hedge that you were mentioning could be
incorporated within the wording of that
condition as well
thank you i think what we want to based
on what we've heard from the parish
council in their previous experience we
just want to be 100
safe that that is secure and there is
absolutely no wiggle room so are you
saying through that that will happen
that can be made specifically clear in
the in the wording of the conditioned
chair john
i i'm happy for the avoidance of doubt
to actually
impose that condition here anyway uh so
we can take that away and word it
accordingly but um can i just summarize
what i've got so far
if i may
so as per your papers with the
additional condition on hard standing to
be permeable for uh private drives
unless otherwise agreed uh condition on
protection of the hedge
near white elm road to be agreed and
condition on
swift boxes in your papers to also
include uh house martin nest boxes as
well as appropriate
and i've got an informative note sorry
to encourage the applicant to discuss
open space adoption with the parish
okay so on that basis we'll go to a vote
please
thank you chair members if you are
select the plus sign in the top right
hand corner of your app
and select attendance and voting this
vote is now in progress
yeah if i could just take your vote
verbally then please counsellor thank
you
chair that's
six votes four and one against that's
carried thank you okay thank you very
much
okay so we'll just uh give literally
three just literally two or three
minutes just to allow people to move
around and move seats and members to
move around as necessary then we'll go
straight on to the next application so
we'll start again at four minutes past
by the clock in here
okay so welcome back we're now going to
move on to the next application dc
2102927
uh which is the application in needed
market i'm going to hand over to alex
scott the case officer thank you
thank you chairman um yes members this
is item 7b in the papers
application reference dc oblique 21
oblique
[Music]
to 02927 uh land northwest of hill house
lane in needham market uh the
application before us today is uh
application for approval of reserve
matters
following the grant of outline planning
permission of the erection of 64
dwellings including 22 affordable
dwellings on the site
the application seeks approval of
reserve matters relating to layout scale
appearance of buildings and landscaping
of the site
only
matters regarding principle
and access having previously been
considered and approved under the
outline planning permission that's
referenced dc oblique 17
0 5 five four nine uh so if we move to
the
presentation
um this is the location of needham
market uh within the district for the
avoidance of doubt to anybody
and this is an aerial view
of the site now the
proposal site is edged in red and uh
it's really divided into into two areas
the most significant portion is uh
this area here which is a portion of an
existing agricultural field which is um
um classed as a grade three moderate
quality agricultural land
and then there's uh a small portion
here in between two existing uh
dwellings fronting hill house lane
uh which is also proposed to be uh
developed as part of the proposal
now the entire site measures uh 2.3
hectares in
total
area
and on to some constraints um the site
does lie outside of the settlement
boundary
as as
designated in the existing development
plan going back to the old 1998 local
plan which uh which is
here
apologies
it's my mouse work there
um and
uh hill house lane itself is a public
right-of-way um even though it does
double as a uh paved road so uh for uh
well all of its length here from uh
stone market road all the way back to
the approximately this point it goes
into the fields beyond the town
and
yes the yellow area there indicates a
a special landscape area and the
majority of the sites as you can see
lies
within that apart from the small portion
fronting hill house lane
now there are a couple of listed
buildings not shown on these maps so
apologies for that but that's over here
at hill house and
the granary which is in close proximity
so
another constraint to be aware of
and this is the site location plan
submitted with
the application by the applicant
and we have the proposed layout in its
entirety there for you
the proposed point of access which was
previously considered and approved at
outline stage
in this location here
directly onto
stone market road
and we have
two
bungalows here
which would access onto hill house lane
and the remainder
would access fire that access point onto
stone market road
there is also a pedestrian access to
stone market road
in this location
and
in terms of lag back-to-back distances
are measured to be no more than um
i'm sorry no less
it's probably more relevant than uh 23
meters throughout the development so yes
a good good level of separate separation
for amenity
and density purposes we believe
now this is a close-up of the
the north
section of the the layout
and the the top corner contains the
public open space which uh
also has the uh
sustainable drainage feeder feature
there sustainable drainage basin
and that is overlooked in two directions
from houses
across the road in this direction and
there so um
a good level of vigilance of that
particular area
now there are um
the affordable dwellings
they are all located in this area of the
site and indicated by the red dots as
you can see moving through into the
southern portion they continue across
the road
and there are 119 allocated parking
spaces throughout the development
and 22 garage spaces that that equates
to
2.2
allocated parking spaces per dwelling
and there are also 17 visitor parking
spaces uh
throughout the development as well
uh in terms of uh triple parking which
is uh i know will be of interest to
members uh there are i think three
instances that would be here
and then two together in this location
i will say that these are um on the um
shared surface areas of the development
which are not proposed to be adopted and
probably in an area this site i think we
would advise that um
you know is not would not be heavily
used by traffic and that has been
considered and accepted by
suffolk county candy highways
now on to some elevations these are some
of the market dwellings proposed so in
total we have
we have three one bedroom dwellings
market dwellings nine two bedroom market
dwellings
thirteen three bedroom market dwellings
seven four bedroom market dwellings
and in addition we have uh four
two-bedroom bungalows uh going to be
market dwellings and eight three-bedroom
bungalows proposed as well and those are
the elevations as well
we also have the garage front elevations
on that slide
for your information as well
now these are the affordable dwellings
we have uh four bedroom
uh sorry four one bedroom apartment
dwellings proposed and that would be
two of these buildings
um in total with uh first with sorry
grand and first floor proposed for
dwellings
in addition there are also two
uh one bedroom dwellings 12 two bedroom
dwellings and four three bedroom
dwellings proposed in terms of the
affordables
now onto materials uh the roof will be
all roofs will be a mix of red clay pen
tiles you can see there at the top and
grey slates
walls would be a mix of
red buff bricks and
would have white mortar and there would
be some
some pale render included
which will be rough cast render
in terms of ground surface materials we
have a mixture of tarmac two types of
block paving there
and paving slabs to
private paths there as well
now onto some street scene elevations
for you
i think
the most relevant would be
this one which would be the main street
scene when viewed from stone market road
with this block actually set back uh
beyond the uh
uh beyond the public open space and
sustainable drainage feature as you're
looking at it from that vantage point
and
[Music]
yeah this is the um
layout as proposed at
outline stage
and we have that compared to
what is now proposed on the right of
your screen so
outline compared to what is proposed
and we have some um
3d computer generated images provided
recently by the applicant
these are plots 41-52 they would be some
of the affordable houses proposed in the
um
in the uh the north northwest corner of
the site
and then a sample of the uh proposed
market dwellings proposes these are
plots 15 to 18.
and on to some photographs this is
along hill house lane
looking
looking north and
this is where the
section of cypher the two bungalows i
propose which would directly access this
highway
then we have the view from the
opposite direction the relevant portion
of the site being here
now this is to the rear of the existing
dwellings threatening hill house lane
and
we're looking at the
main area of development here looking
towards stone market road
and then just moving around looking down
the uh
towards the river valley there
and across
and back to the uh the opposite
direction
this is a photograph of stone market
road this is the hill house lane
access and the existing dwellings on the
opposite side and from the opposite side
of stone market road and the proposed
development frontage would be in this
location and he'll actually
here
and this is just another uh view of the
frontage of the site as exists from uh
stone market road and then some views
across the field from the bottom of the
site um showing the roof ridges of the
dwellings um
who noticed the uh
rays and sight levels from the um
from the north of the site this is uh
north looking south
and then just a view across and you
might be able to make out the list of
buildings here at the granary and
hill house
in the distance
so that concludes the presentation uh as
said out in
the officer report officer's
recommendation um
for approval with conditions thank you
chair thanks very much happy to take
questions to the case officer yeah
council madison
two two questions um
firstly is there
a pedestrian access from the main
site into hill house lane
and second question what's the amount of
tree loss on the stone market road
for visibility purposes etc only i think
it's a very wide verge actually there so
this it ought to be not a big problem
but i'd be interested to hear the answer
apologies um right so
um
answers uh counselor matheson's
questions the pedestrian access would be
in this location
to hill houseway
um i don't believe there is a direct
pedestrian access proposed to hill house
lane no
and in terms of the
the verge uh that is shown to be
protected in the main
obviously they'll need to be a
reasonable amount taken out for the
access and
pedestrian access but uh
yeah that's going to be protected on the
uh on the layout in the main
with additional planting internal to the
site
and to this boundary in terms of
compensation
uh that hasn't come up in any of our
discussions not with the reserve matters
no
okay councillor
thanks matthew just like you asked alex
you put up a picture there of um paving
stabs building materials is my same
question regarding permeability of
driveways and so on i don't know if
that's been discussed but if that does
get approved then i think that ought to
be
conditioned so there's a reasonable
level of percolation through through the
surface
uh yes also there's a
significant surface water drainage
scheme um included as you know part of
our assessment that's been considered by
southern county council local lead flood
authority um they seem generally
satisfied but um yes if it's a
contention that maybe john it's
something we could
think about including
councillor manson
uh thank you chair i think i've got
about three um questions um looking at
the comments from suffolk county council
highways on 168 and 169
um they refer to um the road adoption
issues not being addressed and also
refer to standard conditions about
parking cycle storage refusing recycled
bins which i can't see in the list of
conditions so i'd like to comment on
that
um
okay
um yes in terms of the road adoption um
i think the majority of the site apart
from the shared servicing would be
within adoptable standards although
it's yet to be confirmed by the
applicant
what the intentions are in terms of
adoption
so yeah we don't have that specific
information at the moment
um in terms of um refuse
bins and um
recycle
thing if it's not showing on the layout
at the moment
that
has been or could be secured by way of
condition i would uh i would suggest
having it but it's not on the current
list of suggested conditions at the end
of the report that's all i wanted to
clarify uh next comment is to do with
the strategic housing response which is
summarized on page 171
the strategic housing officer comments
about the um affordable homes all being
in one cluster and the fact that they're
going to be different designs to market
dwellings and yet in the bulk of the
report i think that's on page 175
it it makes out that everything's
hunky-dory as far as um strategic
housing is concerned uh so have those
comments um from the strategic housing
office have been been uh
has any adaptation has any amendments
been made
or are we taking them as current
um well we would uh yeah i mean
you know certainly those have been taken
on board um
however um
yeah it is not uh considered within our
current uh policy
uh gift to ensure that they are more
pepper-potted would that be right
um okay two aspects can i just go back
to your first point which was about the
bins and so on can i just draw members
attention to page
320 that's the outline permission for
this site and that includes uh
conditions um on bins collection areas
highway maneuvering areas and so on so
they still need to be
dealt with
and that so they're covered off that way
so that's why we haven't put them in the
recommendation to apologies that that
didn't quite communicate uh across there
uh in terms of the pepper potting
debate
it's um the problem with
this is that you get to the point where
you've got housing associations wanting
all the houses cluster to get clustered
together so it's cheaper for them to
maintain and and manage and on the other
hand we want to
spread them out because of a potential
social
element that we we are looking at um
at the same time what is important is to
make sure they are all tenure blind in
terms of their visual appearance
um is
ultimately
what what is uh the important point that
they do not seem to be detrimental
detrimentally dealt with compared to the
rest of the market houses
it is a balance there's no specific
guidance or pot well the guidance is the
preference would be to have them all
over the place scattered everywhere
because it but
on the other hand there's no policy to
require that either
it is a judgment
it's a case of if you feel that they
should be peppermint peppermint but
pepper said more
ultimately
what is the harm in planning terms that
we would defend if we had to just refuse
on that basis
and i don't feel we have sufficient harm
demonstrated in this case
thank you thank you for that um i've got
one more comment about the
comments made by the disability forum
they're um summarized on page 171
um are any of those um suggestions being
incorporated
up into this application and its
conditions
um
yeah i don't think we've uh we've gone
into that much uh detail with it um
however that would be something that uh
yeah you know
something we might consider john
um again going back to the outline uh
consent the specifics about the
construction of the paths
you know in terms of the leveling and
stuff will be part of that so that that
can get picked up
with our consultation with the county um
unfortunately though the bits and pieces
that are talking about um
part m4
we have not integrated into a
requirement at outline stage so we can't
push it through to this reserve matters
now similar to what we spoke about in
the last application
thank you okay um
next up is counselor hum
i'm sorry mr thank you
alex if you could just go back to the
photograph of the
stone market road please
face in the
from the south side
next one
that one so i can see quite a lot of
mature trees and and all these spoke
about the maintenance of the verge
can you confirm if any of the trees
going to be kept and and if not why not
um
yeah well i i believe the majority would
be um
let's go back to the
layout to see if
yeah so this uh this bar here um shows
uh existing landscape to be uh retained
and protected
okay so it is me i couldn't see any
little tree shapes and i thought oh well
right okay that is hatched
councillor ebern you were next
um thank you very much chair um i too
was going to ask why the affordables
were all in one place which is against
our usual
requirements um and why they can't even
just be in two groups um
the also with regards to the landscaping
this is adjacent to a special landscape
area and i just wondered why there was
none
no landscaping on the
north western edge as it were adjacent
to the
special landscape area and
as there isn't any weather we can
um ask for some to be there thank you
okay um in fact it is within a special
landscape area um so
um
yeah in terms of the landscaping i mean
it's not um overly structural um but it
is um of sufficient width with um
some mature trees included in that um
so it's just uh whether that's
considered to be sufficient i i suppose
um
i think we would uh we would advise it
it would be appropriate
okay
thank you and next up is cancer field
thank you
environmental issues again obvious um
i note that power nine three talks about
the applicant has submitted a
sustainability statement
um which i think is well i was looking
at one page of it on page three three
one
um
the sustainability officer i think
questioned a couple of things one the
statement about air source or ground
source heat pumps
not used and um
and he
he claimed the um well he's right that
the statement about them
uh not reducing um
carbon uses not correct since the
electricity supply has been largely
decarbonized that's the nation's
electricity supply
so i wonder what current view on that is
the real concern here is
there's a sustainability statement but i
didn't see anything here that actually
ensures that these things are actually
delivered
um
and could you point out whether or not
on that
and the point about the the
sustainability officers issues about um
we're using the 2013 building rigs again
why not the
future home standard and i noticed that
if you compare the
target u values on page 331 with the
future homes and actually some of them
are
certainly slightly better than the
future home standard but certainly the
wall insulation values are
pretty poor
so i wonder if a couple of point
comments on those points
so in terms of
ensuring these
sorts of things
you know could be uh could be delivered
um
i mean it is a um that's a bring john in
here um and this is a there's a point of
principle against uh reserve matters i
suppose
so just looking at the reserve sorry the
outline application i was just checking
i can't see alex any condition on energy
and
no there wasn't okay
so
i hate to say it but that has gone we
can't go back
so we don't actually have anything
to control
that matter that this is that element of
energy energy of renewable
efficiency and so on um
so unfortunately we are going to be
entirely reliant on building regulations
i can only give you a bit of good news
about building regulations um
is that
i don't know i take it members are aware
that uh in on the 15th of december
2021
the new building regulations which come
into effect on the 15th of june onwards
um essentially seek a 30
uh decrease in co2 emissions
um as well as
um
ensuring that buildings are designed to
reduce overheating making sure they're
fit for future
and protect most vulnerable people and
there's a whole thing about ventilation
as well not that we're thinking about
ventilation in the world we're in at the
moment um
ultimately this is all the lead up to
the future home standards of 2025
which is at the moment not adopted but
is something that the government is
heading towards so they are making
changes to building control as we go but
of course that's building control not
planning
could one just ask is that building rigs
that you just mentioned would that apply
to this site or will you say this has
been approved now so it's the 2013 rules
the problem with uh building regulations
is it's the one that you apply at the
time so
if they were to apply for building
regulations now it would be a previous
standard or the current standard
if they apply for building regulations
after the 15th of june
then the new standard would apply
depends on when they make that
application to building control
okay okay
can i just figure it out you know
we get large amounts in these papers
that purely make believe and i
personally find that
not too acceptable you know
we have statements about
sustainability that may just not be met
councilman
thanks chad just um
exploring that sustainability um issue a
little bit further i know what you've
said mr peyton g but
the applicant has said that solar panels
will be
installed on dwellings with suitable
roof orientation
now that we have the layout do we have a
number
who have suitable orientation
you have the appearance of all the
buildings which is the reserve matters
before us i don't know if any of them
show solar panels on
no there's none actually shown on the uh
so why are we saying
the layout before today so we don't have
um solar panels shown as appearance to
judge today and therefore we don't have
anything to secure them because that was
not secured at the outline application
so therefore
that's nothing we can do with that if
the applicant wishes to put solar panels
on and how many will be entirely up to
them
okay so the fact that they've stated
that they will install solar panels on
dwellings with suitable roof orientation
and we are looking at layout
if that was zero to my mind then the
layout of this um
proposal is
unacceptable
so the act defines layout
as means the way the building's roots
open spaces within the development are
provided situated and orientated in
relation to each other and to the
buildings and spaces outside the
development
it does not pick up on plant which is
solar panels in terms of their
orientation and layout
you can't judge that because it's not
actually being shown
it's not provided to us to judge
so that judgment cannot take place
so para93 we can put a line through it
because it has no weight whatsoever
thank you
okay any other questions before we move
on yes cancer madison then we'll move on
sorry um i suspect i was loud enough for
you to hear me
um
yeah so i want to very much welcome that
that section um just going
backwards through the reports of 8.3
on the surface water drainage
um i mean it may just be how the words
have been put together but
the
immediately downstream of
this development um
when that when it drains into the into
the river gipping um there are
particular flood
um problems uh with with houses being
inundated from time to time so um we
would really i would think want this
development to to not
result in any
increased flood risk elsewhere
at all
not um not you know not no significant
increase no increase at all is is really
desperately needed
in these sort of locations
just upstream of where the flooding
occurs so i did want to press that
particular question that are you saying
is that correct what you're saying there
that that the sentence says would not
demonstrably result in significant
increase i think that's i think you're
saying the same thing but john do you
want to just comment any any
i think not demonstrably is pretty much
the same thing alex sorry can you just
summarize for me i'm just catching up on
what this is can you summarize for me
what position from flutters team was on
this
yeah um
conversations with um
um yeah the local lead flood authority
of suffolk county council um
yeah it was my understanding you know i
mean you know i'm not a technical expert
but um you know what i gathered from um
you know the the experts was uh this was
you know not to be a uh any form of
discharge uh system this was to be uh
sustainably drained
you know on the site there would be no
runoff
elsewhere to the river
either controlled or otherwise
and we've so so the flood team have
found the scheme as proposed
satisfactory
indeed right so and in the in terms of
their requirements the the general
requirement for any scheme in suds these
days it has to have a ten percent
betterment on the capacitors or the
outflow of the current site so the field
essentially anything that you put in
there has to have 10 percent
improvement on the flow so it won't say
improvement on the flow the reduction of
flow so therefore
most sustainable danger streams are
better than a field i know that's hard
to actually believe
but the absorption rate effectively has
to be
to the field or it has to be at least 10
better so that's the current standard
they work to we have had schemes so
that's a minimum
we have had schemes that are far better
than that
in the district they are rare but they
do come along occasionally but in this
case we have at least achieved the
minimum of 10 improvement so on that
basis i would say we are quite content
that this would not acid or
increase the flooding at all
in many respects it may even improve it
slightly as a con situation that area
but it would be so on that because of
the whole area filters into that
point you probably wouldn't even notice
that slight improvement but for for this
one field there's a 10 improvement you
know i i think i think that's actually
very helpful so so it's the
it's better than what the words say in
in the report actually which is which is
very definitely very good if i could one
one other thing that i was i was rather
puzzled about but whether officers can
clarify if you look at six point three
and 6.4
6.4 says um
that
in the proposal is also considered to
provide um
you know subject to additional details
being secured by of condition but if you
look at 6.3
it's it seems as if the consultants are
saying that we need more than is
currently put forward
but but the officers consider that the
the
the outline condition is sufficient
uh and and
there seems to be an inconsistency there
either there is more needed or there
isn't more needed sean just want to
comment on the tube 6.36.4
am i looking the same this is open space
6.4 is fine
it's the same it's different
and this is in respect of the open space
areas
yeah
page 176 of the page
176 yeah
okay we've got it it's on page 176.
apologies i was i was uh for some reason
they switched over to the other report
and i was looking at six point three of
the other report that makes sense right
okay so six point three what could
yes
yeah okay
essentially we have already secured
those improvements vast condition 16 of
the outline and if i go to condition 16
of the outline
on page
317
we've yeah so essentially the outline
has already secured the ecology uh
information
and
tied it up to the assessment that was
made at that time for the outline and
that is why that is specifically quote
referenced in condition 16.
to now go above and beyond that
we judge to be unreasonable
because of the fact that we have
specifically secured it
as a specific scheme under the outline
instead
it's actually very unusual that we did
that and i'm not sure why
because it's a personal opinion that
they would like to you know if you get
any consultant from ecology or more
biodiversity improvement the better and
i don't disagree with them but there is
a point of how much
how reasonable we can be in that request
especially in this bit i knew i will say
this is exceedingly unusual i've not
seen this before
we've actually tied this particular
issue up at the outline which i find
strange because it's specific to a
document rather than give us a scheme
later
so
i hadn't come across this before i do
apologize chairman not
realizing this um but that's that's the
way we've done it so i think we feel as
officers that if we were to ask for even
more than what was approved at the
outline
there would be risk of challenge from
the applicant to say we're being
unreasonable behavior but
no they are the uh the consultants that
we've all asked for but we as officers
are saying we've got sufficient
information because of the outline
application okay
um
you can ask for more that might be a
matter of debate but i would say there's
risks attached
okay thank you i'm going to move this on
now there are no other questions oh
councilman yeah um so sorry um to go
back to um section nine of the report uh
and we're saying that i think it was 9.3
we can just cross the line through
because it doesn't mean anything but um
paragraphs 9.1 and 9.2 do refer to
policies 9.1 refers to policy cs3 and
9.2 refers to section 9 of the mppf are
we saying that those don't come into
play because of what's already done in
the outline or can we still have those
as part of our consideration of this
application for reserve matters thank
you thanks that's on page 177 of the
paper
cs3 is the core strategy that refers to
reduction of contributions to climate
change
[Music]
it
has a number of issues because it refers
to things that are no longer in date
not least the code of sustainable homes
for example
those elements
would have had to have been captured in
the outline application as
all housing
submitted would need to comply with they
haven't been in this case as we've
discussed earlier
so no there is nothing in cs3 that i
think is in my opinion applicable
to this reserve matters
at this stage because it's not elements
that we can impose
the nppf
um
section nine
would i suggest talk about the principle
of the locality of the development in
the first place the principle of the
locality is
um
essentially been resolved under the
outline application and the number of
houses are a set number of houses as
well it's not an up two figure it's
actually a very much this will be this
number of houses here so again resolved
by the outline
um
should
incorporate facilities for charging
units and so on that's not been secured
by a condition under the outline
um so
no unfortunately i would say
the reserve matters before you which are
appearance
scale and and landscaping are not going
to be covered by those two policies
okay
thank you so yes
council even i keep thinking we're
moving on another handkerchief yes i'm
sorry it's just that we seem to be
quite some confusion about what is in
the outline and we can't and there's
therefore already kind of
um agreed and we can't change and then
what is in here so for example landscape
which i'm
would like to see more landscape in
particular areas
are we being
can we ask for more landscaping in
certain areas or are we saying that
there's a landscape plan already and
there seems to be several issues like
that of which landscape is one that
we're
can we or can't we versus the outline
thank you what i was talking about
previously was ecology
in terms of the landscaping
um the landscaping if you feel the
layout and landscaping isn't sufficient
uh isn't
in keeping with the character of the
locality causes harm in planning terms
that is part of your debate and you are
more than welcome to look at landscaping
and consider if it's sufficient or not
thank you
thank you
okay so we're not going to move on we
haven't got any on the public speaking
front we haven't got anyone from the
parish council we haven't got an
objective we do have a supporter martin
last and also the applicant is here to
answer questions so you have up to three
minutes uh i'll hand over to you thank
you i'm actually the the agent for the
application
um
with me is mel walton who is the the
owner of the site and the applicant um
this application um for 66 one and two
story dwellings
of which 22 are affordable
some rent and some shared ownership the
affordable affordable provision complies
with the mix and number agree to outline
stage and equates to 35
the appearance of the affordable and
materials used will be no different to
the open market units of the 66 nine
have one bedroom 25 2 bedrooms 25 three
bedrooms and seven four bedrooms there
are 12 bungalows on the site
the site has open spaces and significant
landscaping there are footpath links to
stow market road
turning now to consultative responses
the town council are supportive the
highway authority are happy including
adoption there is in fact a later
highway response than the one in the
officers report
the llfa have accepted the suds drainage
solution
msdc public realms support the approach
taken taken to provide open space
um housing question the affordable being
in one cluster
um
they are in fact smaller clusters
separated by roads and open space and
also separated by tenure
as your officer has said because of the
small number of rented dwellings it is
easier for rp's to have them in one
location for management purposes there
are other developments in needham market
market
that have similar situations to our
proposal
and in fact the application that your
members have just approved had 21
dwellings in
one particular area
in terms of sustainability the current
building regulation situation is that an
application submitted before june this
year would be considered under current
regulations in part l1
however my client is prepared to commit
to constructing his development to the
standard required by the interim uplift
for future homes
and that's in fact what your sister your
sustainability officer has suggested
what that means is that in june and john
confirms it's the 15th in june this year
there will be an interim uplift required
until the new future home standard comes
into force in 2025.
we are happy to confirm that we will
comply with the uplift that comes into
force in june
um
this will involve
better u-values it is likely to involve
pv panels
um
so
we're happy to get on board with that
it will also mean uh that we are
prepared to
try to make the houses as ready as
possible should anybody in the future
decide to convert to a heat pump maybe
with the aid of a grant that might be
available um and that will one of the
things that would include is slightly
bigger radiators um so that the system
would actually work
there are just six objections uh to the
application mostly regarding the
principle which is already established i
would just say that out of respect to
existing
residents most of the dwellings close to
them are bungalows as they request sorry
the three minutes is up so it have to be
the last sentence yeah and and where
that where there are houses the
separation is is 23 meters as confirmed
by alex um thank you very much thank you
thank you
okay any questions for the uh applicants
in the agent yeah councilman
uh thank you chair um it's good to hear
that you're prepared to um um
put um
adhere to the the interim update of the
future
about you values and pv panels um is
there any um intention of your client um
putting ev charging points for all the
dwellings
um
as well
they will all have electric charging
points
and that's what we propose and that is
actual charging points not just the the
wiring ready for them
thank you as we've done on previous
development in need of marker
okay any other questions yes cancer
field
i'm not sure it's really to the
applicant but just a matter of um
when i when i was reading these papers i
put down that it was good to see a
developer who's been responsible which
is what's just been stated but how do we
make sure that that's incorporated in
our paperwork so it's clear what was
being offered and clear what the
committee was accepting
thank you casa matson you had a question
the
we we're all familiar with the concept
of desire lines
and i don't think there's much doubt
that there's a desire line that says
that the people living in these houses
will want to to go in a um
what is it is it a south westerly
direction
um
towards the open fields and and further
up hill house lane and so on
um very popular walking route already um
i just wonder is that we haven't got a
blue line around um
around this site to know what else the
ownership is but um
you know have you considered either
sacrificing a couple of meters of the
the bungalow
one of the bungalows on hill house lane
in order to provide a pedestrian
access or
looked at the possibility of something
um which would um
would actually
exploit the
the end the road end that you've got
um
in that southwesterly direction
um
there's a potential i think that's the
shed
that's the shed path of shed road rather
than the the the spine road so to speak
one of those two
you know have you considered that
because people will kick their way
through the hedge anyway
and it'd be better to do it nicely
so your suggestion is that we put a
footpath link to hill house lane one way
or another
we're happy with that
we can we
oh sorry we
yeah we own the land all to the rear of
this and the side as well
the thing about it is it should be
looked as a more of a master plan
which
at the moment we're actually building
here
so we could easily link it through but
that's obviously a separate
issue on a on a planning issue isn't it
we can't do so
john do you want to come in
oh okay um
what is before us
is what is before us if you're going to
change
the layout which is what you're supposed
to be judging right now
then
i need to find a way of either doing it
that can be done or we have to go away
and come back another day
it's
um
it's intriguing as well because access
isn't part of this
so but i've just looked at the the
outline application and access
was agreed in three part in three areas
the main road to
the main road access to the main road
the corner pedestrian link
but also a cycle and
emergency access come footpath link next
to those two bungalows to hill
lanes so there was
access agreed
just because it was agreed there doesn't
mean when they come in reserve matters
they wish to implement all three they've
only gone for the two which is the two
on the main road
um
what you're asking for is that one
essentially that was agreed at outline
to be put back
um
so access is okay because we've already
effectively agreed that john if the
applicant here today says they're happy
to put a link in there is that good
enough so what i would have to say is
the best way to do it from our point of
view without having to go away and come
back again would be to add a condition
that says notwithstanding the layout of
the two bungalows whatever plot numbers
they're called um a revised layout shall
be submitted to ask for agreement that
would incorporate a
link to hill house lane
that would be the best way forward
page 350 of our pack shows a site layout
that has an emergency and predicted
pedestrian access to her that was the
outline that's outlined that was the
outline so that's the indicative outline
plan but on the indicative plan access
was part so if you ignore all the houses
and just pretend that's a red line
the free access points were the ones
that were agreed at outline and you can
see on that plan you got two of the road
the pedestrian link and the road link
and you would have had
one potential which says in a little uh
you can't see on your but it says their
emergency access cycle and footpath um
so essentially the access
has been agreed that could be
taken forward
what we're trying to get to is a layout
that allows you to get from the road to
the lane just bring in the applicant to
ask
i think historically um when the outline
consent was granted highways didn't uh
didn't particularly want that access we
are perfectly happy to tell you here and
now that if
we that we'll reinstate that access if
that is what members would want okay
well we'll come to that in the debate
but thank you for making that clear any
other questions for the applicant
nope i'm going to move on to the ward
member um and i will take this off i
will read it's quite
long so um
please ex this is from mike norris
please accept my apologies in respect to
this application as i'm currently unwell
having been diagnosed today with contact
dermatitis and i think it's best i do
not attend the committee meeting as a
ward member this application is a
resubmission of that which was scheduled
to be determined
at dc committee a meeting on the 8th of
december 21 but was subsequently
withdrawn by officers i've carefully
reviewed the latest submitted papers and
can see no significant difference to the
original submitted for the december
meeting including the apparent
difference in the number of dwellings
proposed
therefore i see no reason to revise my
original comments circulated on the 6th
of december 21 in respect to this
application which are as follows
i note that there are objections on file
from residents of the adjoining
properties on hill house lane chesford
dodds mead and four wins concerning
overlooking
the proposed site layout shown on page
341 in the resubmitted papers
is different to that shown in the
indicative site layout included in the
original outline planning commission dc
170549
there are now three two-story
four-bedroom proposed adjacent to the
above properties i suggest that to
comply with policies h15 development to
reflect local characteristics and h16
protecting existing residential immunity
the proposed two-story dwellings
adjacent to the existing single-story
properties in hill house lane should be
bungalows which will give more gradual
edge to the development
if this is not possible then at least
southeast facing windows of the proposed
two-story dwellings
should be fitted with obscure glass to
avoid overlooking
also the boundary treatment adjacent to
the proposed footpath linked to stow
market road in this area should be
supplemented with 1.8 meter high close
boarded fence to give privacy for
existing residents
the proposed main entrance to the
development from stone market roan
stone market road shown on the revised
site layout is almost opposite that to
the site for nine dwellings with garages
approved under planning application dc
1803 965 which is currently under
construction
although sec highways have not expressed
any comments in this respect it is
already a matter of some concern locally
that speeding is readily an issue along
this stretch of the b
1 3.
this is evidenced by the fact that need
a market neighborhood watch of authority
to carry out speed checks on this road
and also that a police camera van can be
stationed in this area occasionally
to have around possible 150 plus vehicle
movements a day entering
exiting two sites on opposite sides of
this stretch of road cannot be conducive
to highway safety and i'd suggest that
an alternative position for the site
entrance should be considered
i have a few other comments
on the recommendations on page 178 under
the fourth bullet point those already
imposed by way of outline planning
commission reference dc 170549
however scc highways recommend
recommendation at the foot of page 200
reads
due to the size of the proposed garages
dwellings that require garage to provide
parking in accordance with suffolk's
guidance for parking 2019 will require
additional secure covered cycle storage
along with dwellings that do not benefit
from a garage
this does not appear to be reflected in
either the conditions listed on page 311
or 312 of the papers nor page 178
the recommendation on page 292 paragraph
3 from scc development contributions
manager reads
place-based provision consideration will
need to be given to adequate place-based
provision a key document is quality in
play document fifth edition published
2016 by play england
again
this does not appear to be reflected in
either set of the conditions
there appears to be some confusions with
the total number of dwellings the
description of development on page 165
mentions 64 dwellings accessed from
stone market road with an additional two
dwellings accessed from hill house lane
i.e a total of 66 dwellings
whereas page 173 para 2 1 and para 2 2
mentioned 64 dwellings 62 assessed
access from b 1 3 stone market road and
2 access from hill house lane
the above reasons i continue to be
unable to support this application in
its present form and that's from mike
norris from the need to market ward i i
haven't had anything from the other ward
member
so
i yes questions on the back of that
probably to the case officer uh
councilman uh yeah um uh councillor
norris referred to another planning
application that's already got
permission in this area
could somebody just point out where that
is how many houses it is and where the
access point is
thank you
uh
i don't
unfortunately need a market blue team i
don't deal with blue team um
in terms of i know there's the
development that was allowed to appeal
at the very top of hill house
lane
side there are nine dwellings approved
under dc 1803 965 which is currently
being built out
so can i just give you the reference
number again dc 1803 965.
uh oh right okay
reserve matters
bear with me
all right
yes there is a development on the
opposite side of the vote for nine
houses
um approved and reserved matters given
see where that is on the map
we can try
put up the uh
slide six
please
thank you and so whereabouts is it
located john
you the mouse is here
go left
up
down a bit yeah just there that's just
there that's nine houses in there yep
okay thank you
you take your mask off just i think the
i'm sorry yeah the i think the applicant
has mentioned and in fact i i'd also
identified with the officer just before
the meeting started that there's that he
also owns another development that's
right alex is on it now that that is
what under that's under development are
about to be also and it is adjacent to
this site i think
we see that a blue blue line is quite
useful sometimes
on these things
okay any other questions for the
applicant yes council humphries
thank you mr chair um it's just
clarification excuse my voice again
clarification on numbers of houses i
believe do it 62
22 affordable have i got that wrong i've
heard three figures now
i'm going back to the description of
development
so it's reserved matters for erection of
64 dwellings including 22 affordable
homes so 64. thank you
and the two accessed from hill house
lane so
to my mind that makes it 66 in total
yeah it's the 64 on one access and two
on another if you read the entire
description it that i agree councilman
so that's what it says
okay okay yes it includes 64 of which 22
are affordable plus another two
and of course the outline was for 66 yes
just to help as well on page 174 the
breakdown of those properties and it
adds up to 60 uh
for 66 um is on there as well that's the
breakdown of the properties
okay i'm going to move us on to debate
now it's up for us to this unless you
have any other no sorry we've just had
the ward members there no more questions
we're on to debate so really up to us
discuss
debate and come to a conclusion
um yeah cancer
i field before we move to debate could
you just make it clear the the war
member did ask for some houses the
single story um and i wasn't quite clear
which ones that was because
the the
number
certainly a certain number of houses in
this development back on to the two
that are being provided in hill house
lane and i don't see a great deal of
other houses which which would have a
problem could someone make it clear
which
we're talking about
oh sorry could we
thank you very much okay now i
believe
the properties
council
norris is referring to would be
these two existing properties certainly
we've had um
some significant objections from these
two
occupants um
now what faces then is the frontage of
three dwellings
and
first floor windows
from my measurements
would be um
[Music]
yeah no less than 20 meters from the
boundary
so we're looking at uh sort of there to
there being the
smallest measurement
and um
yeah if i can just get the
so that is plot one
so if i can go to the elevation of plot
one and this will
give you an idea of what would be facing
that particular neighbor so here
so the closest element would actually be
the the garage at single story level you
then go on to this uh this blank gable
here set further back
and the actual windows would be a lot
further back it would be uh 20 meters
from the boundary from my uh measurement
so that's what would be thank you for
that yeah councilman you've got a
question or into debate
well well i'm not i'm not quite sure um
again it was something that council
norris mentioned about the um highways
condition which i think might have been
what i was asking about before about the
cycle storage um because the garages
weren't going to be big enough for
putting cars and bikes in i presume um
and also because if we are gonna um
start debate um what is the um
you know can we put a condition on about
that about
the the comments that highways made
about cycle storage and
um parking provision
will be a question of whether it's
already
covered by the outline i suppose
would we have the ability to impose that
john reserve
sorry i was just looking again at the
outline um
part of the commencement development
details of the os provided for loading
unloading maneuvering and parking of
vehicles including secure cycle storage
shall be submitted to an approved and
writing to us
so that sits as a separate app separate
condition on the outline
um
what details we got here we if we're
saying
if i just go back to the layout bear
with me sorry
close this down
can you give me a moment to come back to
you um just check
where the condition comes in
if we are into debate can i can i um
start um
forming my opinions um i think it's um i
think it's good that we hear from a
developer
who is willing to make some concessions
uh to make homes more future proof and
and it appears to me that we are such
hostages to fortune about what is put in
the outline i really think we need
i know this isn't a thing for today but
in future we we perhaps we need to be
made more aware of it at the outline
stage of whatever goes on as conditions
and outline
um in a way has to be future proof
because this outline was was given in in
2018 and that's getting on for four
years ago and things move at a pretty
quick pace and i just think this is we
need to think about this and remember it
next time we're looking at an outline
permission i know that's not for today
um and i think it was lovely and
refreshing to hear the agent say that
that they were prepared to to move to
the interim update that isn't even going
to come into force until june they are
preferred to put ev
charging points for all the dwellings
and yet we had that that comment from
councillor field about it it's lovely
hearing that but can we guarantee it and
i'm guessing that mr peyton mcgee is
going to say no
we can't guarantee it
we're just on on the promise of the of
the landowner and and the agent and and
it just seems so wrong to me
uh because i think that that they have
thought about things here and um you
know maybe this is a is a well-designed
development i'm not familiar with the
the area
and i just really like it that we could
we could hold
the promises that we've heard today um i
i i think i think on every point i agree
with you i think it's uh it's a lesson
to us all on outlines that it can take
so long and i think you're right but you
know this is a public meeting aired
online uh very you know people are
watching and the developers made a
commitment i i don't know how we can go
beyond that
if i carry on if we can put a condition
in to cover those issues
um that suffolk county council highways
um highlighted about
um
the uh i think it was the shared
roadways and the
um
cycle parking and bin provision areas or
whatever um which does seem to be a bit
of a gray area at the moment and i'll
wait to hear what mr payman g says
so as far as the bins are concerned i
think that's already covered by the
outline and that still needs to be
discharged so i'm happy that that is
self-contained and deals with that issue
cycle secure cycle storage is not as
straightforward because it's tied up in
the removing it's like maneuvering and
turning areas we already know what the
maneuvering and turning areas are
because we now have the layout that
shows us that and so the risk of not
now dealing with the cycle
storage means that there is an argument
if we don't deal with that right now it
won't come back to us because they don't
have to come back to us so i'm actually
going to say that we do need to put a
further condition because in terms of
the layout
i don't have
complete oversight unless my colleague
is going to correct me
on the secure cycle storage
for this scheme so i would say for the
avoidance of doubt and i think because
the outline doesn't completely tie up to
this um i would say that we should
condition cycle storage to be agreed for
the scheme i accept that the point uh
council councillor novice was making was
with regard to non-garages i think for
this for the sake of covering it all off
i'll just take the whole lot and just
say we need to see uh further details on
cycle storage for the whole scheme
i'd be happy to add that condition in or
whoever
talks about that later um
the
point around i will just say one other
thing you said there it's interesting
because we have done actually quite a
lot in the last couple of years from
outlines that we were proving to
outlines we now approve for example your
you know we talked about levels a lot
today ironically one of the conditions
is now default on outline is a levels
condition that all dwellings have to be
level with at least one access it's a
slight improvement on what we did for
years ago but it does show that there
was evolution and i think what we're
trying to take away from today is
there's more that we can be doing and
one key point is perhaps around that's a
disabled element that needs to be pulled
into the outline in future
thank you i'm going to move this on um
so council passwords next um thank you
um matthew very much yeah i actually
like this development and i think um
without repeating everything i think
it's very very encouraging and uh
heartwarming that developers and
applicants are prepared to move and work
with us as opposed to try and resist
things so i think that's very very
commendable
um
and i think we've mentioned one or two
conditions there about drainage
permeability so i i actually am going to
um
propose that we do approve this
application
with the uh
other conditions that we were already
discussed um
i think there was one there that didn't
perhaps get discussed from the council
norris about a 1.8 meter high fencing
for privacy which i do think is
perfectly reasonable it's not a great
cost and i imagine that was for the
three houses that we talked about
earlier but i'm not quite sure so we
need to clarify that but no doubt that
can be conditioned so
um you put all the other sustainability
measures in there as well which i think
is very commendable you didn't have to
do that but you have done it so
therefore i'm going to propose formally
chairman that we um grant permission
thank you very much uh councillor field
you were next
thank you well i i i find it significant
that the need and market to accounts
will support the application
um
and and certainly i don't want to repeat
everything that's being said but it's
certainly uh
pleasing to see a developer who is
prepared to move to the
uh
forthcoming
issue of building regulations we do
desperately want to see the insulation
uh
and sustainability standards housing
improved
and um
this
there
seemed to be an offer here i was very
concerned that that offered appeared to
be in our documents and then we were
essentially told it was all make believe
well
the developers made it clear that he
will go with those statements i'm
prepared to take that on
trust so i think on that basis um
uh and the actual physical layout looks
quite acceptable so about basis i'm
quite happy to second uh
the proposal in a second i've got a
couple of people that want to speak
before we go to the vote council
humphreys did you want to add oh mr yeah
please thank you um and i welcome
34.37
affordable housing in the right place um
so well done on that but conditions wise
um i agree if everything has been said
by the way um have we missed off the
footpath is that going to be a condition
would a summary help at the moment what
i've got we'll do a summary when
everyone else is okay well at the moment
i've got it down as um the footpath uh
cycle storage and a 1.8 meter fence
thank you uh council rebound you wanted
to come in
um thank you chair um one of the points
that um i wanted i made and asked in
questions was about the landscaping and
i'm still concerned that this is in a
special landscape area and the edge of
this development is going to be a very
hard edge um and i wonder if we can
improve the
landscaping somehow down that um
northwestern
was the southwestern edge
northwestern edge of the development
where it's actually
you know it's in a special landscape
area but it's actually now going to be
the edge of it and whether that can be
approved improved in some way with this
development thank you chairman
how can we do that john
if if councillor pasmore and council
field are happy
my question whether there's enough room
with within the red line personally to
get this kind of structural landscaping
i can see the merits and the benefits
but uh yeah i think
we we may be getting into redesign um to
what extent we go into that i don't know
but
what we're talking about here i don't
know if you've got the layout plan is
essentially
the the main area is the rear of plots
34 to 40
and it's their rear gardens that buffer
up to that northern
edge
um
there's essentially a is that about a
meter
hedge meter wide hedge is that the
landscaping detail um it would be double
staggered roses
with a few trees as well is that
established is that there at the moment
uh what to the north no it's it's
completely untreated
um
how
much wider do you want it to be i
suggest i think if we're not careful
because you know we could say three rows
for us can i just suggest that we have
an informative that it would be a wish
to see that bulked up and we would you
know of course we can't impose it but
we'd ask that it's bulked up and looked
at by the age i mean the applicant
consists to be very reasonable
negotiating most things so i think i'm
if you're happy
ultimately the the point of debate here
is whether you feel that that is
satisfactory and if it's not landscaped
sufficiently that obviously is a matter
of your debate and and consideration um
there was a degree of possibly widening
it very slightly but you're not going to
get much more than
that much more because of how much more
imposing of landscaping onto the
practical gardens that are being
proposed here and of course if you then
feel the gardens are going to get too
small is that a complete redesign and
therefore is this design actually
refusable so i think let's go down the
route if you're happy
can i just come back
is that um
the edge you know i'm referring to the
kind of the
the southwest
edge as it were so the long edge
and you know i understand that that
land is all in the
um ownership of the applicant um so if
it wasn't informative then then i kind
of think you know if they can do
something better on that edge that would
be
um that big that would be great
especially given it is a special
landscape area thank you chair for that
i mean i see the agent nodding so i
think that's been picked up
okay i think we're about there uh oh
cancer madison sorry
um yeah i
i think that this this
application is is is generally
fairly satisfactory um
better than better than some we see
which is good and um especially the fact
that the fabric of the building is going
to actually go
ahead
of the minimum requirements which is
which is very good um
but um obviously it's still connecting
to the gas grid which is disappointing
and we we've just um but the applicant
of course has been here to to hear that
the um
the one of the major developers has now
moved
away from the gas presumably there's gas
in wall pit that they've
not connected to
um
this morning um so so generally i think
this this is this is good and we're
getting the connection into um hill
house lane for pedestrians
um
we've been added as a condition we think
yeah
okay well i think on that basis uh we've
had it proposed by council password
second by council field john can you
just remind us of all those conditions
just as we go to the vote
[Music]
thank you so i've got um approved as
papers with the additional conditions of
the first condition would say
notwithstanding plan submitted details
of the footpath link between hill house
lane and the development that may
require revision to the layout of plot
65 and 66
shall be submitted to the local planning
authority for approval and implemented
as may be approved
a second condition is details of cycle
storage to be agreed for all plots
third condition is
1.81.8 meter high fence along the
boundary and i've named the three first
properties
as you're going uphill lane
so it shall be erected and secured
and an informative note to encourage
improved landscaping along all
boundaries
thank you chair members of that vote is
now in progress in your app
thank you members chair that's eight
votes four that's carried
um
are there any site visits planned
okay so we closed the meeting at one uh
about somewhere between 120 123
depending on which clock you look at
thanks everyone